[Music]
david valuetainment giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we gain no value to haters how they run
homie look what i become i'm the i'm the
one
[Music]
[ __ ] i know that offends you what
movie is that
hangover
all right episode 177 today with royce
white we got a lot of things to talk
about today guys i i feel like it's been
too long we haven't done podcasts we got
like from vegas last week we were at the
second
come on let's get real here how sick was
what was that
shack little guy named shaq no big deal
kurt warner we had nellie put on a
concert and i'm missing somebody brian
brian ryan adams img not the singer but
the insurance legend
which was great but today uh we got a
ton to cover before before i have you uh
meet our guests today i want you to know
what topics we're gonna cover today we
got the mar-a-lago raid we got a lot to
do there that's what we're starting 30
minutes before by the way 20 minutes
before we got the salman rushdie attack
with iran which we'll definitely discuss
jamie dimon had a few things to say this
week
china's uh tick-tock employees linked
them profile indicates 300 current tick
tock and bike dance employees used to
work for
chinese state media what is that all
about that's a forbes story by the way
and some of them still do no politics
the us couldn't could lose up to 900
warplanes fighting a chinese invasion of
taiwan but would emerge victorious
says think tank this is an insider story
and then we got a couple interesting
things going on walmart reaches stream
and deal with paramount out of all
people disney apparently passed up
netflix which tom's got some commentary
on that u.s housing affordability in
june was the worst since
1989 and then uh alex jones tom brady
doesn't seem too happy to be playing
football apparently who knows we'll
cover some of that stuff but anyways
royce white good to have you here man
thanks for having me absolutely
for some of the folks that don't know
you would you mind taking a minute and
introducing your background
wow uh where to begin
um
i'm a former college basketball player i
guess that's the starting point not just
the regular one you were you were a very
good college basketball player
very successful uh statistically let's
say
um i was one of uh
one of few players that lead their team
in every major stat category
and that's that's a rare feat for any
for any player in any season in history
but especially in a power six
conference like the big twelve
um especially at the time was very very
competitive at that time so you know
from there i got draft to the nba
very controversial
way um challenged the nba on mental
health policy back before it was a
talking point of the uh
the uh
faux social justice warrior movement uh
it wasn't talked about at all let alone
the way it's talked about now and i get
the nba railed against me for for
advocating that we have some type of
policy around mental health and and uh
shortly after i was kind of
kicked out of the league blackballed so
to speak and i've been there ever since
for the last uh 10 years
so for for some folks that don't know
the story what i recall
is when they were going back and forth
he says royce could be a star in the nba
he could do this he could do that but
you had a challenge with traveling
because it's something to do with
traveling if you don't mind talking
about well i
i've always had anxiety or let's say i
was diagnosed with anxiety disorder at a
very young age 16
came from the first time i smoked
marijuana had a huge panic attack you
would have remnants
or
subsequent panic attacks like two three
times a day for
i don't know about a year
before i finally was even diagnosed and
knew what it was i thought for a year i
was dying three times a day and and you
know if you've ever had a panic attack
it feels like you're dying it simulates
the
the terror and fear of actually dying
so i say i looked death in the eyes a
million times
thousands of times
but when i finally found out what it was
um
you know it changed my life in a sense
and
i i started to understand that my fear
flying was connected to my anxiety as
well
and you know so
really
the fear of flying part of my story
um
was a
misdirection
from the mainstream media because what i
remember
adam correct me on this i remember the
following i remember was saying whoever
picks him up he's only going to play
home games or i don't know why i
remember some of those stories on on how
that was structured i mean that's why
i'm fit to lead really because i had
that firsthand experience with the
mainstream media just corrupting and mis
misrepresenting me in the most blatant
way and because the sports world is very
passive in their their uh premium on
details especially when it comes to
personal stories away from the arena or
away from the court they were able to
pass that story along with with great
ease and they're gonna you know went
around the world three times before i
got to put my pants on
um but but it was a complete
misrepresentation the the real
truth is that um i did have a fear of
flying i still do have a fear flying i
don't like flying uh at all do you fly
do you actually fly but i was flying at
that time so when you were playing
college ball weren't you flying well i
went to iowa state it's in ames iowa the
majority of the big 12 is in texas right
there's you know you can't drive any
anywhere in the big 12 really i did
drive to a game in manhattan kansas
state
and i ended up driving to the ncaa
tournament which was held in louisville
that year that we played but other than
that every away game i flew to and i
even flew once i got in the nba i flew
once i got drafted and the transition in
the summer before the season started and
and even once i was traded to
philadelphia i flew so the entire
me not flying was a way for the
establishment to
write my story off for the passive
the passive fan and and not have a
discussion about mental health which was
really more of a discussion about the
human condition and that's the one they
were really trying to avoid
two questions for you um because you
kind of glossed over it real quick you
said that the anxiety stemmed from the
first time you smoked marijuana at age
16.
was it only one time one
one and done bro like like a freshman
entering the nba
you smoked weed one time and that set
off a whole domino effect of anxiety bro
well i think you know
my my uh
you know
psych psychology
what stems from a bunch of things from
growing up where i grew up how i grew up
as all of ours does um but that that
first time smoking marijuana
was the first time i had a severe panic
attack and have you smoked since at all
one time one and done was a blessing
well it was it was a blessing and then
as far as the nba goes what pat was
discussing you're saying that they
didn't want the real story to come out
they kind of like uh
you know smoke and mirrors it was flying
what was your actual beef who was the gm
at the time the drafty was it daryl
morey that's right okay so obviously
daryl i'm sure you've gotten
had many conversations with daryl marley
he became famous because he was calling
out hong kong and china and the uyghurs
and now he's ironically the gm of the
sixers which you got traded to i don't
know if there's any like correlation
there is all right i'm sure you'll talk
about that um but what were the
conversations like behind closed doors
what was really on your agenda if
they're saying they're misrepresenting
what you wanted to do which was mental
health and they were kind of disguising
it with not wanting to fly what were the
conversations like what was actually
happening
well they did a great job of what the
mainstream media does and that's the the
three card monty right uh the double
cross and the triple cross so they
provide one story and have you look at
this story while there's an actual
secondary story on but there's a third
play that they're actually making
and in my case it was
i asked and let's start with
the mental health policy that i
advocated for
um which was at the time any mental
health policy whatsoever when i was
drafted our collective bargaining
agreement didn't have one mention of
mental health in the entire document
so i advocated that we had we create
some
addendum that either recognize mental
health within the scope of overall
health or we create an entirely separate
addendum of mental health by itself
uh and they didn't want to do either and
they they push back against me the
rockets or the entire well i'll tell you
first
the rockets
said that they were in support of
something like that which they almost
had to because all of the doctors that
were around the situation
were in support of it from a medical
standpoint they all said look
it is kind of
[Music]
negligent to not have anything written
down on how we proceed with mental
health not just from a health standpoint
but just a communication standpoint with
the players how are they supposed to
understand the expectations around
mental health if nobody's even talking
about it so it was the elephant in the
room as far as topics go
and
so so the doctors were in support of it
so the rockets were kind of in support
of it but once we got into the
negotiations
the rockets communicated to us be it me
and my agent management that the nba was
railing against putting up actual policy
in place be it the league office
so at the time that was david stern adam
silver was the uh
the deputy commissioner um and and and
our players union um director billy
billy king uh who ended up getting
indicted and no longer there but he was
there at the time so we had all these
players at the table all these people at
the table trying to discuss what are we
what players were who was the uh head of
the oh no chris paul who was a
non-existent not like zero players were
would never speak out none of them would
never speak out on a real issue
whatsoever these are these these guys
are the the quintessential
sellouts the quintessential black
bourgeoisie
sellouts which players which names all
of them
i'd have trouble naming you one that
isn't really but especially those guys
chris paul lebron
all the guys who have been propped up to
sit like they speak on behalf of the
players or black people it's kind of the
same thing
uh their sellouts so and my story was an
example that which is why
i feel confident speaking on them
because i've been behind the scenes and
seen them be quiet when they should
speak and then i've seen them speak when
they should be quiet
but so the league railed against us
having a mental health policy in the end
and they they even threatened the
rockets
with fines
and
the loss of draft picks if they provided
accommodations like for me to be able to
bust from chicago to minneapolis
and so what they said was well roy says
he doesn't want to fly at all if he has
to fly it all then he refuses to play no
i asked that we put a policy in place
that allowed me to drive when necessary
let's say from orlando to miami
and uh the nba said that would be a
salary cap infringement
which number one it wouldn't be a salary
cap infringement but the fact that they
said it let me know that they were just
trying to pump me basically and that's
what they were trying to do then and
they were even open about that behind
the behind closed doors they would say
things like
yeah you're right about mental health
important issue we should we should do
something about it it's not talked about
in the league but you don't have any
leverage
who are you to tell us what to do but
weren't they right what leverage did you
have you're coming in as a rookie i mean
i'm not coming at you no i'm just saying
you're a real no they were right you
know typically and i've heard the hazing
stories of the rookies not like it's
like uh you know uh they were fraternity
but they were right hold the bags rookie
kind of getting live yeah they were
right but they have no sacred honor
right
when we talk about leverage in that way
when we talk about leverage as a
juxtaposition to what is truthful and
factual
then we set the table for people to be
able to lie their way through any
situation in the world when they have
the leverage over another group of
people let me ask this question about
mental health okay so
basketball in the 90s that's when i
followed basketball closely yeah okay
i don't remember anything with mental
health maybe there was i don't remember
and i remember one story in the 90s not
to get you off sharif
or no he had other issues but do you
remember willie burton i do i know
willie personally yeah well he's
minnesota right that's right i remember
he
stopped playing because of depression
okay you remember this story
people laugh like dude what are you
doing really willie
and i love him to death and if he's
watching this and i'm speaking out of
turn i i apologize but willie really has
some struggles with addiction
as many players did so and when you say
you don't remember hearing stories about
mental health that's the double cross
from triple cross i was talking about
with the media yes is that so they
presented it like when i said mental
health nobody knew what i was talking so
here's where i'm going with this so when
you say panic attack i know exactly what
panic attacks are because i went through
it for a year and a half when you start
a business and you put your life savings
into it and you're about to lose it all
it's very very
challenging because you busted your tail
for a decade to save a half a million
dollars in your 20s and you put in the
business and you're down to thousand
dollars and everybody's looking at you
to pay their salaries and commissions
and you're about to bust and you have to
fee you just got married you told
everybody you're gonna do this and it's
not gonna work out so it's a very the
pressure on you you feel like you're
having a heart attack by the way like an
elephant is sitting on your chest i've
been very open about that
i've gone through i've gone through
panic attacks and i'd go to emergency
i'm like what the hell is going on my
body's like sir you're just having a
very bad panic attack right and then it
would give me iv for a couple hours yeah
your body's exhausted right you need to
this has happened probably
five times in my career okay where i
have to go to the hospital and get ibs
five but times that's no that's no small
feat i mean are we talking i think five
is actually not bad if it happens every
three years it's actually
anyways i'm not going there so let's go
over here so athletes today so here's
here's where i see it so i think there's
a difference between
so you so you know you saw ronda rousey
after the fight oh i was suicidal
michael phelps you know he he went
through it
serena williams even talked about how it
was for her you know uh uh ali raisman
talked about it we have even the recent
one the tennis player
so simone biles so how some mental
health so some some kevin love is even
in that community right kevin love
talking about you guys had a little uh
he was the one to come after me so so
then here becomes here becomes the the
difference how
how
you know there's a part of it where like
when i was going through it i wasn't
public about it i was to myself right
now i was privately talking about it
with my
doctors and whoever i was dealing with
but it wasn't public because your
business you're not really talking about
i talked about it years later when i
went through it but
you know like when you're hearing with
naomi going through it you hear kevin
through go through it what is the
difference between
man you just went through a set of
losses and it's tough and you got to go
through it versus you're actually going
through
mental health how do you differentiate
between those two
well i think uh
was two things
first
i think mental health has been
weaponized
by the
been weaponized through woke-ism number
one
and i think a huge part of the medical
community in the mental health community
the psychological the field of
psychology through the universities
has also been
corrupted
by woke-ism by liberalism
and that reflects in even the
diagnostical
ways to
determine the severity of mental illness
but
i think that's when you get down into
the details
i think in general the premise that i
was coming from is we're not even
acknowledging that mental health or the
human psychology is a central part of
human beingness to be
and and so let's start there and now if
we need to reorient the details
we can do that and and to your point i
think that you know all of those cases
are very different simone's case is
different than osaka's and and and
serena's
kevin they're all different um and they
all carry their own unique unique
signature from a mental health
standpoint but i think very clearly if
people are saying they have an issue
they probably are the question is what
issue are they actually having and what
relation does that have to what they're
doing what they're saying they can do or
can't do in my case i really wasn't
saying that there's anything i couldn't
do based on my mental health which is a
significant difference from
osaka
osaka was saying
i'm having depression i really don't
want the pressure i'm going gonna step
away because i can't perform or take
the the scrutiny or magnifying glass
with what i'm going through
mine was a complete 180 degrees from
that i was saying look i have anxiety
but i can play i can do everything you
ask me to do
i just want us to have an understanding
about this this
topic
open dialogue and i'd like it to be in
writing because everything else in our
industry is in writing
so it was more of a business
uh how much money did that cost you a
couple hundred million a couple hundred
million dollars yeah yeah not a lot of
money just a couple hundred million i
mean if you would have yeah if you would
have stayed in the league for a decade
and got a second contract and a max
contract 500 million yeah i mean uh
likability commercial comm you know all
of it endorsements so say low 2000 for
the people that don't understand royce's
story and we'll get into a lot of it
yeah you were billed as sort of a next
lebron type of like if you're gonna lead
your you're a power forward who also
played point guard right lebron-esque
right six eight strong
court vision rebound pass score
dominate in the fourth quarter like when
you're saying these numbers a couple
hundred million a half a billion
if you would have lived up your
potential you're actually not being
uh facetious with these numbers
so so so for you know you know what it
is for me let me explain to you what it
is for me so i have a i have an internal
uh uh you what do you call it there's a
good
yeah so one is sitting here saying stop
bitching and making excuses and kind of
make it work
and the other one's saying to do it
understand him he's going through
challenges right
and i i tend to lean towards the guy
that says stop bitching that's the guy i
listen to the most
i tend to listen i don't know if i'm
making any sense or not i tend to lean
towards the guy that's like dude listen
you think you're going through hard
times how about the guys that are in war
right now that are not missing their
birthday of their newborn baby or you
know they just lost their best friend
lost the limb and you're sitting here
worried about you're about to lose a
half a million dollars your life savings
grow up you know you're living in
america you're the luckiest man alive so
that's where i lean towards 90 of the
time okay so now here's what happened
when i was going through this process
i'm curious so i go through different
doctors
and 99 percent of doctors recommended
what
drug hey take this hey i'm like no i
want a long-term solution like even
right now my back my lower back on the
right side challenges when i go to
chiropractor and i always ask the
chiropractor give me a long like what is
it i can do one time and it's gone right
and they'll say listen sorry man that's
just not gonna happen you're six four
you know six four and a half you got
military knees your lower back you were
in the army for a few years you carried
that weight this is something you're
gonna have to handle for the rest of
your life okay so
eventually i went to one guy and he
recommended me a book it was like a 60
page book and i read this book
and he explained depression
and anxiety in the simplest way possible
to control your imagination and here's
all it was and it's simplified because
at any point i was feeling i went to
that state he said anytime you're
depressed you're spending a lot of time
living in the past
any time your anxiety and panic is high
you're spending way too much time living
in the future he said try to live as
much in the current
as possible on what you can do that is
the best state to be so if you catch
yourself your brain or your mind is
taking you a little oh my god i should
have done this i regret dona dude you're
gonna get depressed come back to the
present and something what if something
happens what if there's this what if
there's a totally get it you know you're
you're visionary you're living in the
future that's good go there every once
in a while to get excited or kind of
prepare and anticipate but try to come
as much to the present as possible so
for me sometimes when i see this
and a player or an athlete or a pilot or
somebody that's running and they say oh
that that was a lot of pressure on me
and i was going through it as i was
going through that
yeah that's what it's supposed to do
it's supposed to create pressure you
know my kid the other they were at mgm
dylan last year he didn't want to speak
on stage
and he's like no i don't want to go i
don't want to go and this kid's got a
great voice he's charming everybody
likes him nelly the first time he saw
uh dylan he says so you look like an
athlete he says yeah i'm a shortstop now
he's like i was also short stop my mom
was the third baseman i wanted to be a
third baseman but i ended up being a
shortstop he looks at my older son he
says what about you do you play baseball
no he says you look more like the kid
that's gonna buy the baseball team for
your brother to play on right so anyway
so this event i keep telling dylan you
got to get on stage no daddy i'm not you
got to get on stage no i'm not
all of a sudden i'm interviewing shaq
shaq and dylan hit it off like shaq's
telling dylan let's go to the club it's
hilarious
and it's hilarious shaq decides to come
and sit next to me this is the first
time this has ever happened the entire
interview i'm doing in front of
10 000 people in attendance he's sitting
right here to my left and then later on
when i'm interviewing the kids he
decides to come up on stage and he
actually answers the question and he's
like that was so hard i was so sad how
do you feel now that i didn't think it
was that hard after i did it right so
that is there's certain things in life
that's supposed to give us a little bit
of anxiety it's supposed to give us the
challenge so sometimes how do you as an
individual at this age that you've gone
through in many different ways
and there's doctors that deal with
public speaking there's doctors that
deal with acting and cameras on you that
some can't handle there's doctors that
deal with you know political leaders
that are getting out there like that one
guy that couldn't he would stutter they
made a movie after the guy and the
doctor was trying to get him to stop
stuttering the guy from uk what's the
guy's name the the oh the king's speech
the king's speech that he would stutter
there are many different forms of it
from all the people
papers books you've read what's been the
best solution that you've learned
and has anything worked were to the
point that today you can travel without
being afraid without having that anxiety
faith and god
faith in god yeah
yeah my anxiety at 16 was was unresolved
spiritual angst
it was spiritual
right
and i didn't know it at the time but
that's what it was it even you know
despair angst
these things are not you know new ideas
they're they're uh age-old tried and
tested in the in the philosophical realm
these things have been pulled apart and
you know my christian my christian faith
is has given me the best
solution
um an antidote to the anxiety and once
once i was able to clarify
my spiritual
path let's say or my spiritual standing
and my faith as an adult
the anxiety greatly resolved now now i
do think that there are
uh rightful situations for one to be
anxious too and i don't think people
should try and rid themselves of all
anxiety despair is another issue
completely the
natural
they're talked about in the same sense
despair and anxiety but they're really
quite different right and and they're
they they can be anxiety and depression
can be co-morbid but the
the fundamental mechanism of both are
different like you said one has been in
the past and one is is living in the
future so to speak there's a rightful
reason to be anxious about the future
in many cases there's a rightful reason
to be cautious and vigilant
um about your immediate surroundings but
about the um you know the the world or
the path you see in front of you
despair is a whole another deal
despair comes from you being afraid of
the inevitable doom of dying right and a
lot of people have
uncontrolled unconstrained despair
because they have no faith
and when they're hearing that that was
um you got rogan and
and uh the guru talked about this when
your idea of having collapses all you
have is the here and now
well if all you have in here and now
is the here and now you've got to become
kind of nihilistic or kind of
hands off about the idea of death and
well it doesn't matter i i don't care
about anything that's how you deal with
that despair or you become really
anxious about the the great unknown
after you
leave this this this realm this phase
and when you know what that hope is and
you know where to place it you now have
a hope and a certain future and that
hope in a certain future gives people
assurance and that assurance is what
helps cancel
the anxiety and you have to fight your
humanness every day on a spiritual level
to spin that around otherwise you do end
up in despair and i've always seen
despair as like an absence of hope
so despair is like the pit you know i
was in the pit of despair i felt no hope
but
spiritual gives you a target destination
and it gives you
certainty in the spiritual voice
led by the holy spirit which gives you
assurance which gives you comfort which
is what
gets pows if you read about the
christian pows in vietnam that they got
through things that other pows
couldn't at the emotional level not the
physical torture or physical torture
gonna break mar and break your arm it's
gonna happen but the emotional side of
it which th which the
which the liberals and the communists
and the the atheists and the the
satanists make sure to keep away from
all of their discussions around religion
right you know you know what you know
what the thing is with great skill they
keep it away that's right by the way you
know what the biggest thing is with me
and faith here's the biggest thing with
me in faith when i sit down and i have a
debate with anybody about faith okay you
can go and do the mathematical debate
right and it's like you know
we can talk god and we cannot talk god
one of the biggest factors of having
faith is to control your imagination
anybody i know
that typically has a lot of anxiety or
panic they have a very strong
imagination
but they can't control okay and it's let
loose
and this imagination goes to places that
could be dark scary whatever it is yeah
you see shadows everywhere you see
shadows everywhere yeah you know you
know
i got four kids one has a lot of
nightmares one doesn't have any
nightmares the one that has a lot of
nightmares the most creative mind
imagination and the other one's like now
i got to get the job done it's a very
interesting uh mindset on how this thing
works but once you get a hold of your
imagination
and you can have some sort of a faith
that the future looks bright people want
to be around that and that gives you
some peace of mind knowing no matter
what everything's going to be under
control i'm going to do whatever i can
do but whatever i can to do i gotta have
faith to see there's nothing i can do
about it if you don't have faith how are
you gonna worry about your your four
kids your four kids you don't have
control of your four kids 95 of the time
they're out there doing whatever they
want to do you better believe in
something that's watching over them
because you're not going to be able to
do that for them the hours that you're
not around them anyways
let's get into the topics that we got
today okay
so the discussion of royce white coming
here
when we started speaking was because you
decided to run up against run against
ilhan ilhan so tell us how you really
feel about ilhon for some that don't
know your true feelings about her
well i think she's in on it i think
she's a
globalist
i really deep down i think that she's a
security state asset
i asked myself who got out of somalia in
the 90s and i grew up in minneapolis so
i'm very familiar with the somali
community growing up in public school i
grew up with a bunch of somali kids
and have many friends you know growing
up that were somali
um loyal friends good people um so i'm
not saying anything about somalians in a
general sense but when i think about who
got out of somalia it's the same people
that we left behind in afghanistan
there were people that helped us when we
were there
uh and her father
is is rumored to have been um
a rebel
during the time
when we took people out of somalia
and a lot of her sentiments and actions
line up with that i mean who do we think
can just go to cashmere in the middle of
a
geopolitical tinderbox that that's
happening right there and uh meet with
not only the new prime minister of
pakistan but the former prime minister
of pakistan with no government clearance
with no help from the state department
first of all it's a lie that she didn't
get help from the state department but
even with the help from the state
department in that sense in a covert
manner
that's a security state operation in
many regards and so you know she she
poses herself as this democratic
socialist or you know this this
socialist or far leftist women's rights
activist
racism protected whatever you want
whatever you want to say whatever you
know whatever day it is
but really they're running a scam and i
saw it and it offended me because i'm
from the community and our
representation should represent people
um and and the biggest scam is is what i
saw coming down the hatch with the nba
right and not to go backwards but to to
to encapsulate and end my nba story with
my my anxiety was really existential
my anxiety was to say that there's a
global corporate community and that the
nba is a watering hole for a global
corporate community
they're like the cinequanon of globalism
you were saying that back then
oh yeah go pull it up i mean you pull up
the sports illustrated articles i'm
saying this is a global corporate
community this isn't just a basketball
league this is every industry in the
entire world from here to beijing
represented
in a financial interest
and when they say mental health is not
important they're saying the human
condition isn't important and it was a
pretext for their partners their
corporate partners such as big tech
to be predatory around human psychology
to weaponize dopamine
against the average person and that is
what they've done and the nba knew it
back then but not only the nba
their wall street
hedge fund
co-conspirators overlords they knew it
20 years ago
right and so you know that's that
rightful angst that kind of gets woven
in and misrepresented where it's like oh
you're just a kid who
is a prima donna you want special you
want special accommodations you want to
be treated differently than everybody
and that's that's why you're asking for
this and no
no the reason why i'm asking for it is
much much deeper than most people
wake up in the morning make their coffee
check the morning paper and look at the
stats maybe bet by noon want to deal
with
and it's that absence of wanting to deal
with it that that
that people like ilhan capitalize on
they exploit that how does somebody like
that get elected
um
lies help from the mainstream media
um
also you know that
the uh localized identity politics she
was sold to the average somali that says
hey a somali-american just like you
achieving
this next step to actually represent a
constituents because there is no there's
no american race the way there is a
german or a french person we're from
everywhere didn't she almost lose like
by two or three thousand votes tyler
then she almost it was a close race it
was a close race that's why they sold
that but to your point that's maybe on
the initial election but she's been
re-elected how many times three times no
look so like at some point the people in
minneapolis minnesota are gonna have to
all right we either like this person or
we don't i'm no fan of ilhan omar but
she's a representative she's not a
senator the people in her
district have to keep supporting her or
not
let's look at how that let's get one
thing straight
i just ran to become the united states
congressman from our fifth congressional
district
i lost in a primary
by a thousand votes
to a uniparty
globalist
republican establishment candidate
you get the government you deserve
that's the reality you get the
government you deserve and increasingly
we
like our politics with french fries and
ilhan gives you everything that you need
to feel good about your politics with
friendship but isn't that just plain
politics royce like for instance for you
correct me if i'm wrong you've aligned
yourself with steve bannon yeah yes or
no yes so how palatable is that to the
people of minnesota maybe if you're in
alabama using them as an example hell
yeah let's get behind steve bannon let's
do it
what's the you know
sentiment in minnesota a very
liberal-ish type state super liberal who
all right or city the outstanding yes
well every city in america literally
every major city votes blue most rural
votes read not even minnesota not hawaii
is the most liberal state new york
minneapolis specifically but when you
align yourself with steve bannon just
that name alone people are going to be
like yeah i don't know about that royce
sorry about that buddy well even worse
than that they don't say they don't know
they go they just write it off they
write me off that's my point but and i
think that when you lose by a thousand
votes
doesn't that come back to bite you in
the ass no no no no no see no absolutely
not tell us why
sacred honor
and i'm going to keep going back to it
as as many times as necessary because
this is the great crisis of politics
whatever i need to say wherever i am to
win the game is the ultimate goal
and when you play the game like that
it's kind of an american or post-modern
business practices when by any means
we we have to win we have to continue we
have to move on we have to go upward and
onward
um but it's egregious for for morality
or ethics or ideas
and that's why most people especially in
politics have betrayed their ideas
across time because their idea is i need
to say whatever it is that will appeal
to a person to get me elected when
really
your leaders your elected officials
should stand for things things they
really believe in things that are true
first and foremost but things they
really believe in and then be able to
convince you that you should believe in
them i don't i don't know about that i
have a hard time with that and let me
explain to you why why i'll challenge
that a little bit and you can disagree
with me yeah so
in business uh i've lost a lot in the
last you know 21 years of being in the
financial industry it's a very
very competitive i've lost a lot of
clients to other companies i've lost
agents i've lost employees
i've lost contracts
and
you know it was very easy to say well
you know in the industry today
uh you know it's because i'm armenian
it's because i'm from iran one time i
lost the contract to a big company
because they were concerned i was
armenian and you know uh uh what do you
call it there was a couple armenian
insurance frauds going on in glendale
and they said you're part of that
community i said no here's where i'm at
this is my business is this model so
well we had a bad experience because we
had a two million dollar charge back i
said no i said i want you to judge me
for who i am i don't want you to judge
me for what my ethnicity is let's see
this and let's see what we can do and i
want to compete and i kept our contract
we're best best friends till today the
same people that were going to drop my
contract 11 years ago they had me at
their retirement ceremony speaking
amongst five people and i was second to
the closing speaker and the closing
speaker was his best friend of 26 years
so for me
the the challenge i have is
to to say i have to you know compromise
my values to win
i'd much rather say my messaging has to
improve my ability to go out and shake
more hands has to improve my ability to
market better has to improve i have to
out market you out message you outwork
you even if you're cheating and there's
a lot of people that cheat in the
marketplace in business in media and
politics definitely more in politics
than other areas yeah you got to get
more creative with the messaging to win
because
that that that angle and again this is
my opinion yeah that gets the voter to
say
well why vote anyways because we don't
stand a chance against the globalist why
do it anyway that that's actually the
wrong messaging because it doesn't get
the crowd to come out for example like
right now what happened with trump
okay
right now what happened with trump for
example
th this is the
uh uh brilliant marketing of him and
where he's at love him hate him do
whatever you want to do with the guy
do you know how they're gonna use this
here what that happened with fbi here's
how the market
they're gonna get their base
to show up
like never before okay that's how
they're gonna use it because in the
world of politics
it's it's definitely the dirtiest
amongst all okay because you can
manipulate a lot and get away with it
you can't really do that a lot in
business and get away with it because
there's laws and politics there's not
really laws you just got to kiss the
right person's ass and you know
you can like get away with a lot of
different things in business you're
eventually going to get caught when you
lie too often it's just it's just what
ends up happening if you do that bad
business yeah it's bad business and
insurance you can send a bunch of
premium but if doesn't stay on the books
you're eventually going to be
you know having that reputation so
for me i i want to agree with you but i
want to also challenge you to say hey
man if i got to go back i got to change
my strategy marketing we got to have
better team we got to shake more hands i
got to build a bigger pipeline today i
got to get better endorsements maybe
bannon is good strategically maybe it's
not a good public strategic thing for me
to have out there maybe i got to have
him as somebody i talked to on the phone
on a daily basis but publicly the people
that so that's the only thing i would
say with some of those things because if
you're really going to go do the
politics thing
you have to know like i remember one
time i had a guy named casey bell
he was in the military total playboy
great with the ladies and one day i'm 17
18 i'm like i just can't stand the games
these girls are playing he says what are
you talking about
they're playing so many games he says
you got to play the games back
it's part of it it's a game no but but
by the way not no not from the
standpoint you don't play games
not from the standpoint of not from the
standpoint of manipulation what he's
talking about is they're playing hard to
get that's part of it
you got to figure out a way to still woo
them you got to figure out a way to
persuade them that's the part and by the
way that's politics
yes
no
no i strongly disagree with this okay
tell me why
there are sacred honor are the ideas and
the values that you live by but are
willing to die for
and to have a radical loss of sacred
honor in this country um and people
around the world
and
as soon as you you know when you say out
message i mean
and i and i told our our delegates this
and and the
cd uh five
convention where they endorse a
candidate
um
if you guys want to become democrats to
win in a deep blue
place you don't really win
i mean you don't win if you become a
democrat to get a democrat vote you have
to convert a democrat to conservative
ideas or liberals to conservative ideas
if you become a liberal to win you're
just a mouthpiece
you're just saying that though but no
but this but but this is what i'm saying
there are fundamental ideas yeah that
didn't fall on or didn't fall to a lack
of messaging there are real contention
about ideas and because we live in a
democracy we play this retail game with
the people and say well how can i get
the widest net but there are some things
that we should have never compromised on
that somebody has to stand up and say
just just know
absolutely not and in a place like
minnesota that's uh
very moderate conservatives even on the
republican side
abortion was that issue
i could have went door to door and
affirmed abortion baby killing
and i would have easily got another 500
what i'm saying though but but when you
start down the path
of modifying a message
based on what people would like to hear
as soon as it ventures away from being
truth things that you know to be true or
or things that you believe in yeah
you're already down you become
you become a product of whatever the the
most powerful
leveraging dog is out there in the yard
and that's how this that's how we lost
this country so i'll give you an idea
okay do you know what life insurance
used to be called
death insurance death insurance mm-hmm
so would you rather buy life insurance
or death insurance
wouldn't matter to me but the average
person is gonna buy insurance so maybe
that's insurance has a creepy moment but
if you go you go to a family and say hi
i'd like to buy you some death
insurance today versus life insurance
right okay
so you know uh uh
anti-abortion or pro-life what's better
exactly it's the same thing it used to
be it wasn't being called proliferation
same thing so
abortion or pro-life
you have to know that's messaging it's
the smart thing
okay so i just came from with all due
respect yeah i just came from the
political arena where these ideas are
discussed
it's not a messaging issue these are
fundamental ideas that people are yay or
nay on on the other side the problem is
the people on the yeah the people on the
good guys side let's say
are
wishy-washy about their stance
so it allows half of them to always get
pulled over that this is the overton
window shift that's happened in this
country and why liberalism holds the day
and everybody looks around like how did
these crazy liberals and these ideas
take hold yeah but but then but then
that becomes conservatives failed let me
push you and then push me back as well
okay
so say you win with a pro-life
okay
say you went with a pro-life message in
a district and where wherever you're
going to minnesota okay say you win
say i'm pro-abortion and i'm pro-choice
can i co-exist in your district or do i
have to leave you
um you could co-exist if you don't want
to kill babies
what if what if what if for me i'm
pro-choice
yeah well then i mean that's
no just no
so then so then i have to leave your
place leave leave the district you're in
no you could not have uh sex and have to
get an abortion that's an option
right but you could even be on birth
control you could track your ovulation
schedule there's all kinds of things you
could do before saying i have to pack up
and leave so how about how about if
you're somebody that
you believe in low regulation okay yeah
and i believe in high regulation you
believe in low taxes i believe in high
taxes let's just say
but do you want to also
win me over long enough where you want
you can convert me or do you want to get
rid of me what would you rather do um i
think right now we're at war and when
we're in a crisis so
we need to clear the smoke first okay
sort out the details so under normal
circumstances different
um but but right now we're at war yeah
so so i want to believe you and by the
way i think if we get to the point where
it's war and all of that
and you know there's a part of it that i
don't disagree on what the fbi is doing
what no we're at war when they put 87
when the irs is going to commission 87
000 i heard say
we're at war with our government i mean
that could be an interpretation of what
it is i don't disagree with you but then
again
if you are
your base
is a percentage and the other set is a
percentage 44 46 whatever you want to do
with it your your job is to win the 12.
your job is not to change the 44 right
you know whatever they're saying you
have to win them with the truth
shorter mbas
they go back to nba yeah
they're a prime example this is why i
had such this is why i was so offended
by the nba and their whole outlook on
the world
they're chameleonic with their politics
this is woke is this in effect is what
vocalism is you think the nba really
cares about the lgbtq now mind you lgbtq
ism is is a is a tenant of the the left
and liberalism in america today but at
bottom the adam silver doesn't care
about the lgbtq he doesn't have a deep
profound care in that topic
the audience that he's
either
mapped out or or has imagined in his
head at the concept his head that's what
matters to him
the the black people who
create the culture of of basketball and
you know the the the the nature of the
swell of the game from a commercial
aspect and a culture aspect that's what
he cares about you think long term that
works uh no no okay so the market's
gonna decide but but no that what i'm
but that part to me is look at how much
they tried to push blm down everybody
but but it didn't work
nba's ratings dropped dramatically that
season no it did work no it didn't work
because people still watch the nba as
though it has no cultural impact oh my
god those ratings in 2020
tucker carlson would get up and show
data and say look what happened to the
nba him and mark cuban would get into it
and look you know no they got destroyed
the market said we don't like it we just
want to watch basketball not construct
they're not destroyed because
one the game
is is is different than the commercial
and the politics and the game is
evolving the game is increasing young
people more than ever are watching
basketball at a higher frequency than
ever in history on the internet sure
they might not be tuning in to the live
games but the the the trickle down of
basketball content
is 10 degrees magnified than it was when
i was a kid for whatever reason but you
got to realize okay do you do you
believe
do you believe um
okay do you what percentage of america
you think has the ability to reason
i'm being serious it's like what i'm
trying what
what percentage you want to be i'm not
trying to you know i'm not trying to be
disrespectful to them totally fine it's
totally fine all i'm this is what i'm
trying to say yeah
we have been corrupted misguided misled
represented um strategically manipulated
philosophically yeah we don't teach
philosophy in schools we don't teach
people to critically think
makes it easy to create this
tacit sort of fake political arena where
it's political theater and then you get
your puppets coming and they kind of
just ping to all of the talking points
that are already set in a low resolution
philosophical
discussion and it's like
if you're a candidate or you're somebody
who really wants to lead people in a
time of need
you can't adhere to any of that you you
can't play any of that because you'll
never talk about the real issues and
this is why
for me as a candidate in cd5 i came in
at globalism
uh the fed
the church of lgbtq abortion god
and my opponent my primary opponent did
exactly what what what you're saying
that she should do strategically to win
is she got up there and said oh that's
red me talking points for the base
that's that steve bannon stuff
we can't win in a deep blue district
like that
what would make people think that she
would actually represent a conservative
viewpoint or or values if she were to be
elected
what would make a democrat think that
she would represent democrats even
though she should be are you a fan of
trump
um
are you a supporter
of yes okay yes so what did he run on
trade and and uh trade and
immigration did he run on pro-life
no no and that was an error but but but
wait a minute that was an error but but
no it's not an error no it was well let
me let me challenge you let me challenge
you let me challenge you okay
so you're an april 10 baby right yeah
okay my dad's an april 10th baby and i
love april babies i hire april babies
okay to me they're very
true believers in what they're in and
they stick to it right okay i lived with
that man for 43 years okay so it's a lot
of strong values that he has okay
so trump ran on what he ran on
the wall
okay he ran on train
he drank
swamp okay all three so look look at
this guy on what he ran on and you would
have liked for him to run on pro-life
you would have liked for him to run on
faith god you would you would have liked
for him to render all those things
absolutely okay let me ask you a
question what just happened to roe v
wade
um
we took a good step in the right
direction how did that happen
the supreme court
stood up and grew up who picked those
three supreme court donald trump
would he have done that if his messaging
was hardcore only pro-life he wouldn't
want
so so the message i'm trying to make is
some because it's all pure strategy
so the strategy isn't that he
he may have done something impossible
three
it drove them insane they lost their
minds that may be the single biggest
victory a president's ever had people
today are sitting there saying holy [ __ ]
i thought being a president mattered
no
it's supreme court because you got you
got six three now five four whatever
it's gonna end up being for how many
years are you kidding me so maybe power
to him for strategy that's all i'm
saying i'm not saying compromise your
values i'm not saying compromise what
you believe in i'm just saying
messaging is
where i think like for example today
okay republicans who cry uh
and at the same time cry yeah
republicans who cry like john boehner
type of christians but there's a no no
there's a lot of no no left rights
anywhere you go you go boehner cry
you go uh uh you know mega you go
lincoln project you go
uh uh whoever you go to who's like cry
like cry foul or actually crying tears
come on
well listen isn't forbes for sale
isn't forbes for sale for 630
how many republicans have gone and made
an offer of 400 million dollars to see
if they can buy forbes if somebody on
the left buys it you deserve everything
they do when they announce woman of the
year award forbes magazine last year
international woman of the year award
you know what they give it to hillary
clinton you deserve it you tell me you
can't spend 400 million dollars to buy
forbes every time these media companies
that go on sale why don't you go buy
props to daily wire for what they're
doing which is you know the the the
uh uh
shapiro on his guy jordan
props to seth um
so dylan with babylon props to these
guys that are doing what they're doing
temple props to there's a lot of these
names that we can give to they're going
out they're pushing the envelope but if
you don't like that your argument's not
being heard do something about it and by
the way they're doing something about it
royce my opinion
is a 20-year solution it's not a one
year no it takes 20 years so put put
your money where your mouth is
not you anybody in the market that's got
the millions or you really care about
america you really care about your
conservative beliefs they're not they're
not real conservatives then then that's
the problem yeah no and yeah no i agree
yeah 100 no
most of my campaign has been to speak
out against the republican establishment
or the conservative movement as a whole
from an ideological standpoint even from
a strategic standpoint
there's no way that liberalism has run
off with a with the lion's share control
of the mainstream media without the
conservative or prominent conservatives
or powerful or or conservatives that are
in a position to actually affect
these industries there's no way that
they did that
uh
by chance
it didn't just happen
they were in on it they were always you
know but that is the uniparty so for me
to not be able to say uniparty in the
public square out of fear of people not
knowing what it is or comprehending it
as they would a a more palatable issue
uh uh really
strikes against the deficit that i see
in in time to solve this issue and it
may be 20 years but then we've got to
get started with the truth one million
percent yeah one million
and trump should have ran trump should
have ran on pro-life
yeah
he not singularly
but i do believe that as a leader of a
movement um it is your duty to to hold
and plant flags and be able to merge the
message together in a way that you could
go back to later even even though he
didn't he did more for the pro-life
movement the last 30 years than any
other president who ran on pro-life did
so that that's the part about
i don't who is the who's the democratic
strategist behind closed doors who's the
democratic tom who is the biggest like
who do they call for strategy behind
closed doors i i think their socrates
still is james carville so he's still
james harvard you think is running
the raging game no no i i i think you
you're asking me about democrat
is that biden strategist or is he
obama ron claine yeah susan rice
i i still think james carville is in the
car what do you say what do you say
with respect to the biz doc i don't
think james carville is pulling any
strings over there i mean maybe under
clinton but i still any success obama
remnant susan rice
david axelrod axelrod okay who's on the
right who's the strategy spanning
closers for the right donald trump
period end of story
he's consulting with that i'm asking a
real question who's the strategy it's
the karl roves of the world people
you're gonna do
you're gonna lose with that the the
republican party is not behind donald
trump it's all a facade okay these
people do not trust donald trump you
maybe have three people in congress
you're saying like the mitch mcconnells
of the world types of people
kevin mccarthy even the kevin mccarthy's
the bill barr who is the most uh
who's the guy
that understands the lincoln project
community and understands maga and is
able to reason and give you straight
down the middle counsel who's that guy
is there anybody with is that a tucker
who is that guy carlson maybe who would
be that guy that can sit do you know
what i'm asking so
i think that's the challenge not the
dick cheney liz cheney no no no
they're all democratic gonzales
i don't know if they're all democrats
they're just not mega no liz cheney is a
democrat royce you can't say that
her father ran the republican party for
they were taken and they were democrats
and that's what people are feeling you
can say that they're more closely
aligned
i don't know what i'm saying there's
nothing about what i'm saying dick
cheney that screams democrat everything
screws didn't look at him he's a
globalist he's a he's a raging neocon
military-industrial complex shill he was
a matter of fact he's not a shill he is
the
you're not wrong about that portion but
that doesn't mean he aligns
not on the liberal side of things no no
no
the neocon side of things and the
warhawks what are those things in the
military they report themselves to be
just because you say your thing doesn't
make you it just like because i say i'm
a christian doesn't make me one
my actions have to add up and more so my
ideas and base have to add up and and
kissinger was a democrat
nixon was a democrat lbj was a
republican
this is the uniparty scam that the
american people have been hoodwinked on
and they get caught up voting instead of
voting candidates who actually speak to
real fundamental issues
and and that's the great scam that's the
great retail politics game that has been
been casted upon us and it really
undermines the the idea that we live in
a representative uh republic or uh
democracy at all because we don't we
live in a we live in a shadow shell game
of of of of
faux teams fake teams fake ideologies
liz cheney's a democrat
signs up lines up on the republican side
when it says go she's the outer bastion
of defense
for the entire thing what do you think
joe walsh's
do you know who that is
yeah i i i think uh
because don't you dare call him a
democrat royce away he will come at you
like a spider monkey look i i mean
liz is a little bit more clear-cut
that's what i'm saying there are some
people you could pick out but yeah
there's a lot of republicans out there
who have quote unquote left the
republican party joe walsh being one of
them who will literally walk out of a
podcast unless you have to like embrace
them
if you call them a democrat they're just
saying i am no longer republican but i
am not a democrat so people don't want
to be labeled certain things yeah when i
say they're democrat let's say liberal
you're right new york liberals neocons
um
these the list chainings of the world
pretend like they're conservatives
but there's nothing conservative about
about their stance on anything they're
chameleons number one they serve
themselves in their own career agenda in
place in the thing but
you know secondly they greatly they
greatly serve the movement over that way
to the left okay can we can we get into
some can i just ask you one quick
question because this is this and then
we're going to get into something
russian iran go ahead the whole argument
you guys are having i'm just kind of
going back in my head to
a um
how-to that you've done and i've
discussed this kind of stuff before is
whether you should pursue
money or your passion you've done a
board episode about this right money or
passion yeah should you follow the money
or should you follow the passion i don't
want to put words in your mouth but
clearly you've followed more your
passion than the money you've given up
close to 100 million dollars if not more
my question is
is it not better to follow the money
have a hundred million dollars plus in
the bank
then go to create change versus being
worth whatever it is
and try to fundraise and try to play
that game
and not have any money in the war chest
and then tried to win
come from behind victory like i don't
know what your resolution was with that
video but i
i think you recall following the money
not the passion and then once you get
the money you could work on your passion
that's a that's a rational one life
that's a that's a one life uh position
there that means it's only one life here
on earth and you need to modify it and
go back and forth because exactly the
core belief is what good is it if you
gain the whole world but you lose
yourself very soul exactly so a one life
a one life perspective said this is it
and i need to optimize what's at the
table right here that's a rational point
of view
for folks to take now i happen to think
that it has severe eternal consequences
but you could say this is the playing
field and these are my rules so i'm
going to optimize for that you can
i happen to think that there's that
there's a longer more important
play
you know in eternity that also dictates
the playing field where i'm doing
much
for many and i choose not to optimize
for myself at points along that because
i want to do things
differently what does that mean in
english
i'm not being sarcastic you went very
deep with it what does that mean what
should people follow their money or the
passion uh i i the truth
yeah but that doesn't work you lost the
election bro if you follow no no no he
doesn't know maybe you could have gone
wait wait what what is it
when you think i'm saying he's following
the truth and that's righteous that's
great no there is only righteousness
when you have faith
and that's where this country has lost
itself and this is this is the
fundamental issue where many
well-intended well-meaning good people
have been roped into the very conspiracy
and corruption that they say they oppose
but they're roped in
because
you he what he's saying is that there's
a time horizon mm-hmm there's a time
horizon uh that all of our actions are
taken into account you're 31 years old
right how much you're not 51 you're not
81 you're 31 years old
in the prime of your political career
okay
right you're just kind of getting going
you would have a lot better chances to
do what you want to do with the hundred
million dollars in the bank versus a
million dollars in the bank that's
ultimately what i'm saying
it's not like you're some old man who's
what i have to do to get the 100 million
i don't know if you would have maybe
worked with the league a little bit
better you could have played in the work
with the league the the shill for china
the show for the ccp but this is my
godless tyrannical regime in i'd rather
have a history i'd rather have a hundred
million than the ccp whatever it is no
it's not seen that i'd rather have a
hundred million in the bank big problem
and then it's not a way to come out and
speak out against it now not whatever it
is i'm not taking a hundred million
dollars from satan for him to trick me
into thinking i'm speaking out against
him late
what do you mean you're saying from
satan who's satan he he says the nba is
but by the way
satan
the whole the whole regime they're all
they're all openly anti-god they're not
even hiding it they're saying it right
out in the open if you believe in jesus
christ if you believe in god you're
either a conspiracy see conspiracy
theorist a quack or you're a white
supremacist i watch the nba religion no
no pun intended i've never heard that
you haven't seen it but you're not
sinking it across the liberal
establishment media they're all in on it
together
the washington post the new york times
uh mother jones the guardian they're all
in on it together they're saying they
have the exact same message and the nba
stands back
as this sort of
you know unique
cog in that machine and they go we don't
have to talk about god at all
but we're going to affirm all of the
other anti-god movements lgbtq blm
women's right whatever the other you
know all of the other ones but we just
won't speak on god but they're right
there at the table with the ccp they
won't speak on the ccp the ccp are
locking up anybody who has faith
and they're not even shy about it the
uyghurs for sure i mean the uyghurs is
right out in the open
but the christians the tibetans the
i mean what are we talking about who was
satan they they're all i could see if
they had a a non-position on god they're
anti-god and they're very abashed about
it
yeah so why would i take 100 million
from them to speak out against them and
do you actually think they would let me
do that
if it was after you leave the league you
could do whatever you want well what
happens in that what about
see when you're there's a lot of people
out there are going to be like dude i
hear you i understand they're
that's the exact those people out there
that would say oh yeah i know man but
the 100 million the money the war the
the game of today must be won
they lost us the game of 10 years down
the road 30 years ago
this was kissing kissinger could say the
same thing oh we went to china because
the labor the the unions pressed the
market too hard and they made it unfair
or hard for the american business to
operate here in america with fairly so
we opened up china but wasn't that
richard nixon republican
a democrat
richard nixon was a democrat now yes
holy [ __ ] royce i i maybe all the
history i've learned is the democrat
before richard nixon is a democrat he
was a democrat before first of all he
was a democrat before he became a
wrestler i've never heard number one
never heard this i've always thought of
richard nixon as a republican gary
goldwater was the real conservative
nixon was the favorable likable
more moderate
and where's barry goldwater in the
history the annals of history he was the
forefather of the conservative the
modern conservative movement yeah he got
wiped out no he didn't get wiped out the
same establishment that pushes gender
theory today paints barry goldwater as
an extremist domestic terrorist white
supremacist
and that's exactly the game that's been
run on the american you have this cons
not you personally but i'm saying and
many people do have this concept that
whoever holds this it's real
machiavellians whoever holds the sword
has the power
but christians don't believe that we
believe god has the power and the truth
has the power across the iteration of
games
not so you could win today with lies and
i could die today in the pursuit of
truth but that's still winning
and when you when you don't have faith
you can't come to grips with that and a
lot of people who even say they have
faith demonstrate how they don't
when they say i have to win today or
what was the point
no the point was there was a set of
values and ideas and something that was
right that you believed in that you were
willing to live by
and die for but if you never start the
dying for the good thing
the bad folks have just yet to run away
with it so what are you willing to die
for
the truth
the truth it's very simple and what's
the truth that that we don't understand
well i think i said
and politically i think there's a uni
party
of people who have posed as one category
category the other be a democrat
republican but ultimately they've served
in the interest of the political elites
and they've served in the interest of of
uh
of of a globalist agenda
and and they're saying that right out in
the open too you know when they send
down a house resolution
that that that suggests the military
should be able to pursue
and
persecute american citizens
without congressional oversight in the
name of fighting domestic terrorism
or a pandemic let's say
pandemic misinformation
we are being run by a foreign authority
we we we have given over our
rights and our sovereignty to a foreign
governing body
and it's it's not being hidden that's
what's so frustrating is like
these things they're so arrogant they're
so confident in their position
and the the position they've carved out
of authority they don't feel they have
to really lie
so it's not that they're not telling the
truth so much as we the people
don't want the burden of freedom
we've given up our sovereignty we've
given up all right we did it so when i
go into my congressional district i'm
not going up to the door and bringing
the moms and and and kids out and giving
them kisses and lollipops and slapping
them on the butt because it'll help me
win i'm telling them the truth
the government you watch on tv that you
have your complaints about exists
because of
you that's the difference between me
and most politicians not only now but
throughout time and that is the truth
we've traded our freedom for security
and materialism
so
that's his truth by the way the one
thing you got to respect about royce
very very obvious you're a true believer
there's zero uh breaking into
uh uh his belief system let's get into
some of these topics as a story in 940
we haven't had any topics yet okay
salman rushdie
uh the author of
satanic verses so salman rushing on the
road to recovery after life change and
injury sustained
and stabbing the suspect accused of
attacking him may have had contact with
iran iran's revolutionary guard court
this is an insider story author salman
rush is on the road to recovery after
being stabbed roughly 10 times in an
attack reports uh say may be connected
to the iran's revolutionary guard he was
attacked friday as he took the stage to
give a lecture at chattanooga
institution uh i'm sorry uh shadow uh
can you pronounce that for me uh tyler
it's not shadow walk is it uh chattawaka
chattawakwa institution in new york he
sustained three stab wounds to the neck
four to the stomach punctured to the
right eye chest as well as laceration on
the right thigh
highly moderate the 24 year old accused
of stabbing a sympathetic to the shia
extremism and may have ties to the
iran's revolutionary guard corps 1989
iran's cleric khomeini issued a fatwa
column for russia's assassination
claiming his book the satanic versus a
magical realism novel inspired by the
life of prophet muhammad was against
islam
the prophet and the quran and by the way
iran claims it was not involved in the
stabbing
they made comments on it the country's
foreign minister spokesperson nasser
kanani said in a briefing to journalists
that iran should not be accused of any
involvement we in the incident of the
attack on salmon rushing the u.s do not
consider that anyone deserves blame and
accusation except him and his supporters
nobody has the right to accuse iran in
this regard iran has offered more than
three million dollars for anyone who
kills rushdie a semi-official iranian
religious
foundation raised the bounty for russia
in 2012 for 2.8 million dollars to 3.3
million dollars and i believe khamenei
in 2017 and 2019 said that the fatwa
was still on so royce any comments on
the story
please don't blame us but the bounty's
still out there
where to begin um wow
yeah i mean
i i think
yet and still our security state and um
that the propaganda around it makes
these situations in the middle east all
of them
uh very very murky waters you know to
underst who's playing what angle um
and
yeah i mean this is uh adam what are
your thoughts on this look uh i learned
about this term fatwa years ago and i'm
just going to read the definition a
fatwa is a legal ruling on a point of
islamic law aka sharia law we've heard
that terminology before given by a
qualified jurist in response to a
question posed by a private individual
judge or government if there's you know
you use the word question someone russia
has definitely questioned sharia law for
sure okay so juris issuing fatwas is
called a mufti and the act of issuing
fatwas is called ifta fatwa have played
an important role throughout islamic
history taking on new forms of the
modern era okay the important role that
it has taken on we've seen that play out
over the last few decades
what's the magazine in paris that
basically did a cartoon
of the prophet muhammad how many people
ended up dead and murdered so
um
let's not forget who america still is on
the world stage there's a lot of
authors artists
speakers out there that cannot use their
voice in whatever country they're in
especially in the middle east especially
in iran yeah you can throw china into
there and they come to america as a safe
haven to use their voice so here's a
person who has been who has embraced
america i think he's from indian descent
i want to say indian slash iranian and
he's used um
he's in
lived the united states so he could use
his voice and this is exactly
what you know you want to use like
liberalism or what the traditional
liberalism is
come here and say what the hell ever you
want to say i might not agree with you
but i defend your right to say it so
this is this is a disgusting act of the
of fatwa if you will and by
make no mistake the iranian government
or um the ayatollahs are very upset that
this guy didn't finish the job so how
about yourself well uh
anybody who looks at
the statement by iran you know
how can you not see through that
um
you have no right
you have no legal right to blame us but
the bounty's still out there folks it's
three million and it's rising everybody
wants a tribute used to be two million
and they they they've increased the
bounty on his head and i think you you
look at the radical radicalization of
young men and here's a guy 24 years old
that is the age you know
16 to 24 is the age of for these clerics
you saw the uh the london subway
bombings they traced it back to these
clerics that found isolated muslim young
men and they radicalized them and at 22
23 24 this is now your time
here's your vest go to the subway and
let's do it um and it just it's got all
the fingerprints of that it's just this
is
this is this is tragic for
in
i want to read a hardline story so
here's iran's hardline newspaper praise
of salman rushdie's attacker this is a
reuters story the hardline
kahan newspaper whose editor-in-chief is
appointed by iran's supreme leader ali
khamenei wrote a thousand braavos to the
brave and dutiful person who attacked
the apostate and evil salman rushdie in
new york adding the handed the man who
tore the neck of god's enemy must be
kissed
the answer iran news site on saturday
carried an often cited quote by khamenei
that said the arrow shot by khomeini
will one day hit the target the the
headline of the hard line vatan m roose
uh newspaper read a knife in salman
rushdie's neck the hostron
horizon daily uh carry the headline
satan on the way to hell so here's
here's the thing
with these stories okay that you have to
be keeping in mind
bill maher said something uh a couple
days ago because you know salman rush is
one of his friends a good friend of us
and you know he's probably going to lose
his eye by the way okay and really yeah
he's probably gonna lose his eye and do
you know what he was talking on at this
event he was talking about on the
freedoms to be able to talk about
whatever you can write about and talk
about that's what this whole tour was
about so he's going out there talking
about that and this guy comes in stabs
him three times in the neck four in the
stomach in the eye
gonna lose his eye in bad conditions
he's making it whether you like simon
rush you or not or agree with what he
wrote or not
you know
bill is trying to say
name me any other religion that their
extremists are doing things like this
and he says as much as america wants to
avoid this topic it is a discussion that
we must have so now couple things do you
remember years ago when trump uh under
his regime they killed rasam soleimani
do you remember when that happened
yeah we talked about the revenge and you
know how long oh yeah the airport
missile that's right
so what did they say oh you know revenge
is coming it's going to come on whose
terms
on their terms you know it's not going
to these guys in iran they don't forget
this is not something they sit on and
they move on to them
it's just a matter of time before they
get there especially right now i don't
know how many stories you're reading
about the fact that iran wants to go
after trump did you see these stories
about uh
uh they just tried to kill john bolton
too they just tried to kill john bolton
trump's another one that they have on
their list but look
this is real this isn't like you know
these types of stories when you're
reading him and you're hearing the
support from the back to say kissing the
hand
of the person who
the hand of the man who tore the necks
of god's enemy must be kissed
being written by this paper
that is the editor-in-chief is appointed
by iran's supreme leader ali
khamenei
you know you have to you have to
understand these types of things won't
happen in america
these types of things happen it's it's
stories like this that gets you to
realize freedom of speech in america
this is not happening from an american
to an american this kid that did this
the 24 year old that was connected to
the iran to iran you know where he lives
this kid is he was born in california
it's not like he was born in iran yeah
this kid's a u.s citizen
natural born he was born here and they
get to him and he goes up there and does
what he does and right now you know
we're going to see what's going to
happen with it but um i hope more of
this doesn't become a normalized thing
we don't get too many of these stories
happening it's unfortunate that they did
it to him i remember when the fat will
happen they were burning his book all
over the place and quite frankly
the the book
is actually not that great of a book
the fact that they gave him a fatwa
took his book to
you know levels of selling god knows how
many copies because khomeini gave him
that fatwa there's literally
celebrations where
have you seen these videos they're
they're around fire and they're throwing
the book in fire they bought this book
to burn it they bought it
amazon is a 10 pack for those of you
going to the inferno this afternoon
well it's
ironically what's making me think of is
just free market capitalism is because
look at prohibition
no more liquor in america that's it well
what happened people were making
moonshine in their bathtubs so this is
one of those things where it's like no
don't don't don't look over here no
salman rushi it's like that's just gonna
empower
more people to be like hold on why can't
i go what do you mean hold on
and it essentially enabled his book to
come become a national bestseller
international bestseller but when you
try to
outlaw things
black markets uh emerge and not that he
needed a black market to sell his books
but if you try to
stomp out something it's going to
re-emerge as something else and that's
the problem that i run did you hear
about what happened with jk rowling when
jk rowling goes up there and she says
you know i hope he's okay she says this
on twitter uh horrifying news feeling
very sick right now let let him be okay
and somebody responded on twitter a guy
named uh mir asif aziz
replied don't worry you are next okay as
this is reportedly an iran-backed
islamist extremist praising rushdie's
attacker it's it's i mean and by the way
i'm curious did this person get banned
on twitter or are they still active on
twitter tyler do you know this of course
they're still active i'm trying to find
the article now yeah they find that out
though it's it's um the kid deleted his
account i don't think twitter did
anything i think the kid deleted it well
pat can i ask you a question being from
being that you're from iran yeah
and that you're a christian and that you
had to leave the country you know after
the iranian revolution what have you
experienced in terms of i'm not saying
that you've had a fatwa but you ain't
going back to iran anytime soon i'd love
to go
exactly
what's your experience as a christian
from iran and where does this story kind
of fit into it all well i mean this is
why we live in america this is why we
escaped to come over here because
stories like this
in iran it's it's it's uh i'm not saying
it's every day but it's normal you don't
say anything about the regime in iran
period say anything about khamenei iran
see what happens
say anything you want the other day
uh uh
women were doing a march and taking down
their hijab you know hijab and all of a
sudden i don't know if you saw this
video or not shots fired these are
ladies just doing a basic protest in
march and saying hey we don't want to
wear the hijab
i mean it's just the the game is a
different game of imposing fear for you
to shut your mouth
and that's their way of weaponizing the
people it's just straight up with a gun
and we're going to kill you can't
destroy you in america the way they're
doing it is a different way
in america the way they do it is they'll
take your voice away from you yeah
they'll censor you there's different
methods to kill a man killing a man it's
not just a the life life is i actually i
asked a friend the other day about trump
and what's going on and they said if
this last thing with fbi doesn't work
there's only one thing left
yeah exactly if this thing with fbi
doesn't work there's only one thing left
and the way they'll do it is
you know again this is just a pure story
that was given to me the way they'll do
it is
having another country do it that would
make sense to not have it be on
america's you know on on the internal
political party but deep state yeah so
anyways
harvey oswald and cuba sir
there's many creative ways
yeah and we're trying to get in touch
with the guy but there's many ways
uh you can do it anyways that's a story
with salman rushdie so real quick how
many more of these instances have to
happen before
the powers that be actually wake up and
have a conversation about this like this
insider article no motive had been
identified right twitter doesn't want to
ban this person that threatened j.k
rowling bill maher even said i want to
quote him here don't come at me when you
say islamophobia when you say phobic
just a way to shut off the vape and it's
not islamophobia but one of the powers
that be gonna actually have a
conversation about is
is this a violent religion does it come
with violence as adam said people have
been headed for drawings of the prophet
of muhammad uh ayan hershey ali made a
film the director of the film uh
something van gogh was was stabbed to be
headed like
how many more of these things have to
happen before we actually have this
conference when you get people like bill
maher
who starts saying things like this
and all of a sudden people on the left
and people on the right not the left the
democrats and some folks on the right
start agreeing on things like this
that's purely common sense that's when
you have to do something period because
let's just say i'm in the nba let's just
say i'm part of this community right and
behind closed doors a superstar hasn't
happened in the nba yet because
everybody that talks orlando magic 611
you know
uh jonathan isaac yeah yeah you're not a
superstar so you have nothing to say you
want to stand up good for you ian is
cantor yeah you're nobody
not in your nobody we've had a man
you're not an all-star you don't have a
voice actually i think he may i don't
know if he was an all-star but he's had
14 10 stats he's a decent stat okay not
an all-star yeah so
he's a 60 million dollar your guy okay
uh
you're right but but if a if in the nba
all of a sudden
a guy comes out like giannis and says
something they have to listen to him
okay and the way yana says it in a very
gentle way he would not say it in the
way that
you know
lebron would say shut up chump shut your
mouth chump i don't know what he said
you know
steph curry doesn't want to show up
anyways or whatever he said to you know
if somebody like giannis comes out in a
respectful manner if some of these stars
come out and do that the entire league
has to take notice until that happens
when bill maher comes out and says this
you have to take notice because bill
maher is an all-star he's not just an
all-star bill maher is a superstar in a
media space so when superstars like him
on the left or democrats come out and
start saying things like this
you're kind of cornered are you talking
about radical islam specifically any
argument i'm not just giving you radical
islam radical sum is one of the topics
yeah on any topic when somebody from
your base comes and says
i don't know dad i don't know i think we
have to do something about this yeah i
think we got a problem here you have to
pay attention to it well you remember
the debate that happened on bill maher's
show regarding radical islam
ben affleck and sam harris ridiculous
and uh
and uh who who won there who lost there
well clearly sam harris won
ben affleck got very emotional and he
goes oh so you're the expert on this
he's like well matter of fact i am i've
written books on this and here's the
reality of it
batman at the time didn't look so strong
um but
you brought up the concept of radical
islam this is the only religion in the
world where you know you run your mouth
you're going to get killed
it doesn't happen in judaism it doesn't
happen in christianity it doesn't happen
buddhism and i have a lot of islamic
friends muslim friends respect god you
know god bless you i'm not coming at you
but this is a point of concern excuse me
you know what for the last 20 years
running and you can go look this up
you know it's the most persecuted group
on this planet
muslims by other muslims no christians
yeah that's right
go look it up go look at
for another time
um what do you mean for now's the time
make your
point christians around the world are
the single most persecuted and
exterminated group
on basis of pure faith
you look at what's happened in darfur
you look what's happened in indonesia
that there is a genocide that's going on
here the first
country in this world
that was
a
single single identity single identity
not not polytheistic but single identity
christian was armenia and suffered a
genocide that still no president of the
united states has stated it was a
genocide
you go back and you go back and look
biden actually did come out and say
something in the beginning of his
presidency i think you recall that
biden did say something about it
shockingly enough
can i say
can i say one thing about the the islam
piece
islam has a bunch of problems
their religion
in my view
has not evolved
the way the other two abrahamic faiths
have evolved
and
the the the the tenet of violence is
obvious i i don't think that it's
islamic islamophobic or prejudice or
racist to just acknowledge the tenets of
what you see before you
however
it does occur to me that
as i watched the mainstream media pit
all sides against the middle
that the
criticism of islamic phob
of islam even in the conservative
movement
it's somewhat of our own weak faith
because
let's take the afghanis for example
when the afghanis say
and this is also a double cross of
triple cross an example of that
it's it's people taking the lord's name
in vain but they're right to take the
lord's name it's just what they do with
it is wrong it's the same way america in
its early stages our founding fathers
took the lord's name in vain right we
christians have a better religion than
you so it gives us the right to
persecute and kill you build a
civilization based on our faith so i'm
not a religious zealot i can see where
the errors of religion
take you know great shape torquemada um
but
the afghanis for example are they wrong
to say that we want the west out of our
culture
out of our everyday life
that we want the contemplative to be at
the center of our life
and you know there
there's a subtle there's a subtle racism
in it
and i don't mean to say racism
culturalism whatever you want to say
when we go
yeah but that third world life you live
in the mountains with the goat and the
hut
that's not really living
right i mean there's a real arrogance
and supremacy and anti-humanism in it
and that's what ben affleck was trying
to say in that bill maher piece but he
was saying it in a sort of weird
perverted distorted liberalism fake woke
hollywood way because he doesn't have
the depth to really touch at the real
issues because he's on the same grift on
the same teat
of the people who are oppressing the
somalis who were pirate in the somali
war that was us so there's a rightful
criticism of the islamic world of the
west of trying to encroach and create
this this stage of economic imperialism
and cultural invasion the question is
what is their response what's a proper
response what's a righteous response and
it's never a righteous response to kill
innocent people
in the name of god
and and that's where islam i think has
strayed egregiously from from the path
of genuine faith is it it
my understanding even of the islamic
faith
nowhere
nowhere is a reasonable read of the
koran
um
you know allow for somebody to kill
innocent people in the name of god and
if they have perverted in that way then
it's way off the mark so but
we have to also
as westerners as americans going forward
in the america first movement even
realize that
we provide the the we provide the canvas
for them to weaponize islam in their
part of the world
they get to reasonably say hey look the
americans they're they're they're
security state war mongers and we are
and we have been and if we pull
ourselves out of there we allow
the radical islamists to show who they
really are to their people and not use
us as an excuse so that's
i mean look at the quote from the
iranian newspaper to your point about
using god as uh
as the the righteous the
way to do righteous things on behalf of
god
quote unquote the hand of the man who
tore salman rushi's necks
his neck the aka god's enemy must be
kissed a thousand bravos to the brave
and dutiful person so they're using god
as the scapegoat or their justification
for why
this um apostate should be killed using
god do you think god is actually looking
down on salman rushdie and saying that
he's the enemy and he should be killed
yeah according to
no you know that's sharia law he is i
guess that's
i take that that's my interpretation of
using taking the lord's name in vain
yeah
yeah pat
are we ready for mar-a-lago to get into
it let's go to maryland
okay it's only 45 miles away anyways if
we wanted to drive there but it's better
let's just put on the podcast
for yeah maybe maybe maybe a little more
actually maybe six less than an hour
away yeah there's a lot of people there
right now have you seen it yeah all over
the place i'll tell you it's real quick
from for
six months after the election i would
come down through palm beach i went
north to uh to indian town florida and i
tell you six months every day people
would be bridge after bridge after
bridge on 95 south just hang in there 10
12 15 people everybody had a flag
everybody was representing everybody was
out for trump it's crazy the people that
will go out to trump to palm beach to
this area in support tyler you were one
of them what are you talking about you
drove you didn't just drive by listen
there sorry boy don't worry with your
sign stop to steal we all know you were
there tyler it's like you want to kind
of defend i don't have a sign i just
have that
okay so before we even read some of
these stories adam what do you what do
you what are you thinking with what
happened there
what am i thinking yeah when you saw the
story about the fbi
uh we didn't do this live we were at an
event i was in las vegas when this took
place out of nowhere when trump wrote it
on truth network where we just got the
mar-a-lago was raided
fbi agents came in they took you know a
number of boxes 27 boxes removed from
mar-a-lago 11 of which contain
classified documents is what they're
saying
four sets were marked as top secret
three of them were marked at secret and
three others were marked confidential
and then you hear all this stuff and
then trump says on truth social number
one it was all declassified
number two they didn't need to seize
anything they could have had any had at
any time they wanted without playing
politics and breaking into mar-a-lago it
was in a secret storage with an
additional lock put on as per their
request they could have it had it any
time they wanted and that includes long
ago all they had to do was ask the
bigger problem is
what are they going to do with the 33
million pages of documents
many of which are classified that
president obama took to chicago and now
some are saying it's some nuclear
information was there and then they said
why wouldn't the fbi allow the
inspection of areas of mar-a-lago with
our lawyers or others present
made them wait outside in the heat
wouldn't let them get even close said
absolutely not so the the the
insinuation the claims they're making is
there may have been some nuclear
documentation in there potentially but
when you saw this what was the first
thought
well
most people have their mind made up on
trump already nobody nobody's gonna be
watching this and being like okay based
on this story how do i feel about trump
you either feel that he is a national
treasure or national hero and that's
what side you're on or that you think
that he's a national security risk
straight up so
you know if you want to kind of look at
the left and the right on this you can
say all right this is politically trying
to reason exactly try to reason i mean
i'm just trying to be in the middle here
just try to reason most of america you
know they're weaponizing the justice
department and it's basically just sort
of political theater and that or then
there's other side of the coin that's
basically saying no these are legitimate
concerns these are very serious charges
what are they breaking the espionage act
and yeah and you know basically
obstruction of justice so um at the end
of the day everything's going to fall on
merrick garland he's the one who signed
off on this i think the first couple
days they were like how did this happen
who's the person the doj what's going on
merrick garland who infamously was
passed up for a supreme court justice
under obama mitch mcconnell we all know
that story oh no no he got over that
yeah exactly so is it
is it feeling better now right but i
don't think he took this lightly when
he's and i'm not i'll know merrick
garland personally i don't know where
his mentality is at but when he signs
off on this he has to realize oh [ __ ]
this is some serious you don't think you
don't think we're raiding the the home
of the president ex-president united
states you don't think by noon
i don't know i don't want to speculate
so
let me let me ask you i mean i generally
don't know percentage-wise i know you
don't know but percentage-wise
so think about it if you're going to do
something garland you're going to do
something for the first time and it's
never
ever
happened before ever you got to call it
happened before and it's under your
watch as a president
would you want me garland to call you or
would you want me to do without calling
you if you're saying or is it likely
that biden knew yes it's probably likely
i don't know so come out so it is likely
that he knew likely
if you didn't know what does it say
let's just say he didn't know if biden
didn't know what does he say about biden
who's running the show it shows weak
leadership if you don't know first of
all for you to go out there i don't know
for the record i don't know what biden
knew or didn't know i'm just saying that
this comes on to for merrick garland
he's the one who signed off on this he's
the attorney general i i get that but
the department of justice falls under
him i'm talking did biden know yeah
maybe i don't know but we don't know
that yet that's not what i'm asking you
try to reason with me so if he didn't
know okay assume you're biden i'm
garland
i do this
knowing the opposing side is gonna say
well you know they're trying to hurt
their number one contender et cetera et
cetera would you not want to know before
i do something different agree with you
yes so you would probably want to know
now if i said i guarantee that he knows
i don't know now let me ask you a second
second question say i intentionally did
it without telling you
that'd be messed up correct not only
would it be messed up but secondly it
would mean what
you're a nobody that you don't have
control that you don't have control so
just so you know if they take the
position of oh biden had nothing to do
with it weak leadership if they take the
position off
exactly
no matter which way so that one is the
next one now here's the other part
if it's so classified why'd you wait 18
months
that is the one thing for me forget all
the conspiracies forget everything i
have one question if we're really here
just to protect we the people whoever
that is
of whatever party at whatever time in
history it's really here to protect we
the people why wait 18 months i erase
all the conspiracies everything like
that i even reasoned in my mind just
like you said did bite no diddy not no
good lord what's going on here but i
come down to why did you wait till now
if this was really a problem and you
were really worried about that woman who
coulda or probably was a chinese spy
with the the the the hidden camera the
hidden camera in mar-a-lago that they
found that they found while ago says oh
my gosh there were there was a potential
chinese asset there 18 20 30 months ago
it was a potential chinese asset this
could be classified stuff we got to go
over there right now isn't that the way
the government should respond yeah so
why do we wait until now
well they've had communication with
trump's lawyers they didn't just come
out of nowhere apparently they were like
hey you got to return the whatever and
then he's like yeah we've already done
adam adam let's let's reason through
this point you're right there was a lot
of
reasoning and discussion done and back
and forth back and forth but if it was a
national security issue of nuclear
secrets of level one there is no
reasoning it's go protect the republic
and bust down the door including the one
with the extra lock and get that stuff
and put it someplace safe secure so that
that to me that to me sounds reasonable
to do that right if it's if you're
saying it's such a national security you
know risk
you waiting 18 months shows a lack of
responsibility and leadership again so
go both ways go say it is okay and you
waited 18 months weak leadership
go say it's not and then you waited you
so both ways you're losing leadership
and irresponsible yeah weak leadership
and irresponsible
the other part is when uh andrew cuomo
comes out and he says
hang on a second he comes out and he
said doj must immediately explain the
reason for its rate and it must be
more than a search of inconsequential uh
archives or it will be viewed as a
political tactic and undermine any
future credible investigation and
legitimacy of january 6th investigation
this is what cuomo said now
a pundit came out and said the following
cuomo is wrong doj doesn't have to
explain anything they never announced
they searched mar-a-lago trump did he's
the one who politicized it by stealing
documents
refusing to return the documents and
pretending to be the victim after he
broke the law okay so that's the
argument being made and cuomo by the way
is a guy that can't stand trump for him
to say what he's saying now
and he also just redid all the floors in
his house he doesn't want all these fbi
guys with their boots running around
bill maher said the following bill maher
said fbi raid might have saved martyr
trump from losing to desantis and gop
primary calling trump the luckiest man
in the world his fortune was finally
falling the big lie was finally losing
momentum desantis was beating him in the
polls you know how he hates this more
than anybody
desantis i had this one in the back and
now i got a run against president martyr
uh bill maher says as he impersonates
desantis mar argued that the raid was
saving trump politically because it has
caused all the republicans to rally
around trump so did this help
or hurt trump adam
look
i
trump's ceiling is 42
whatever the number is
the the bigger question number one i
don't i don't think that desantis would
beat trump in a primary in a general
i've been very clear i'd much rather
have a desantis rather than a trump i
think the question that we all need to
ask ourselves is whether you're a trump
supporter or not let's pretend i'm a
trump supporter for a second i'm gonna
put on my trump hat
these things are not going to stop with
trump again
pretend i'm a trump supporter
how many like look at the track record
russia russia russia impeachment number
one impeachment number two quid pro quo
january 6 insurrection mar-a-lago
what gives you the idea that if there's
four more years of trump this nonsense
isn't going to go on again if i'm on
team trump and i'm saying i love trump
he's the best president ever he's making
america great again that's amazing
at some point the exhaustion and the
fatigue has a set and it's like holy
[ __ ]
everywhere this guy goes there's another
drama whether it's shooting himself in
the foot or whether it's basically the
leftist agenda that's coming after him
but the reality is every few months
there's another trump saga
you're talking about hunter biden again
get back to trump
i don't know what that means however
it's so listen to what you just said
it's so exhausting with trump again
pretend i'm on team trump here
every three months every six months
there's gonna be another political drama
that you're gonna have to run through
but you say that it's gonna as though
these are trump's doings i'm just
again pretending i'm a trump fan yeah
this is the reality there's another
impeachment coming down the road there's
another but if you're pretending there's
another drama goals that's not what
they're saying the trump fans are not
saying that no i'm
everything i just said was not my
opinion you hang on everything i've just
said is exactly what happened did he not
go through two impeachments
let me ask you a question you're not
saying
whether those things were true or not
all you're saying is
a trump brings a lot of drama that's
what you're saying
so you're not you're saying russia was a
hoax you're saying the impeachment
didn't really
a trump person your premise is a trump
person is going to say gosh this is all
these things are too fatiguing that's
not what the the
that's not what maggot said magga says
all these things being voiced it against
our hero
they're not saying i'm fatigued so
that's my point
my simple point there you hang on right
was that the trump fans are not saying
they're fatigued they are saying they're
fatigued they're tired as the liberal
establishment trying to attack their boy
i just go go for it i disagree with that
i think there is some fatigue in the
maggot movement and there has to be
and it's go on un unrightfully so
um
i think the response to people
weaponizing the truth and manipulating
and using it to try and bully you into
emotional fatigue should be
opposed vehemently you should never give
way to somebody who's marked you out and
said if we just keep lying enough
this person will ride off into the
sunset we won't have to worry about
that's how you lose a country that's how
you lose a country in grand fashion
which we have but i do see
as a rising voice in the america first
movement in the manga movement and in
that circle that many people
are
[Music]
criticizing trump not necessarily for
the rightful criticisms that there are
but more along the lines of these
contextual well if he runs again then we
have to look forward to more of this and
it would just be better if desantis had
his day and you know my my concept of it
again going back to earlier is um the
the greater scope of it is the people
who we oppose the forces that are
coalesced against us spiritually
politically ideolo ideologically
emotionally whatever
they are opposed to
donald trump at a deep level it's not
him
he's just his current scapegoat if
desantis wins and he got in
there would be no way that they would
look more favorably on desantis and not
try the same taxes on tactics on him
unless he abandoned an america first
position which he might and and and i'm
as i'm on team trump
but i'm gonna say something that the
maga movement might not like right now
um
this is all moral hazard
to what i was telling you earlier when
you
don't tell the truth when it's time to
tell the truth and fight and die for the
things you believe in when it's time to
that it comes back to bite you and we
talked about this 10 20 50 hypothetical
time horizon well donald trump's time
horizon on moral hazard just just
knocked on his door right now and it was
only a few years later
because what he didn't do
as america first as he was as
trade as he was as immigration as he was
as
anti-liberalism church of lgbtq drained
the swamp as he was
he didn't deconstruct the administrative
state
he didn't gut the intelligence
communities and he should have
and he had the he had the juice to at
least
lobby for it
but even he
in
a flawed manner and again i support him
running as the as the candidate in 24
for the gop and becoming the president i
think the country needs him right now
but we don't want an echo chamber in the
america first movement
and any maga supporters who want an echo
chamber and don't like anybody who has
any criticism of trump they're not real
americans
they're cucks
he should have deconstructed the
administrative state he should have
fought harder to deconstruct the the
security state
but he didn't because he likes his
security
and in trying to move these institutions
we all fall victim to our own personal
relevance to him
and this is the moral hazard he actually
believed that the military was behind
him when he was the president and then
our guy milly was talking to china
behind his back he was never with him
right barr betrayed him
all of these people that were in these
positions betrayed him and he and and he
actually was pretty moderate
like i can tell
from the things that he went for the
things that he said and the people who i
know were behind him and the spirit of
what he really was trying to do
he was moderate on and he tried to do
that to appeal
to a centrist
uh uh you know a more centrist
spirit
and it bit him in the butt
now the security state's coming after
him and who's going to say who's going
to help him who is there to help him
the republican establishment's in on it
mitch mcconnell would love to see donald
trump's head up on a pike you know there
aren't enough
uh can uh consistent reliable america
first movements in the entire united
states congress to protect him from a
weaponized military security state
that's the moral hazard he should have
busted up the administrative state but
he didn't because the people around him
that he put around him to advise him
said
be moderate
we don't need all of the antics
on these certain things
and the security state was one of them
the head of the fbi should go the head
of the cia should go the head of the nsa
should go the head of the dod should go
after afghanistan that hold it back the
head the whole thing should be gutted
but they hit us with the fear-mongering
they go if we get if we got all these
security state institutions you'll be in
mortal danger you won't survive 24 hours
if we get rid of these people
these are the people who have stolen the
country and donald trump has fallen
victim to it just now well he appointed
the head of the fbi christopher wray
it's on him so
you get to look yourself in the mirror
but you got it but also when you're in
that position and you go to appoint
people as heads of agencies
a lot of the suggestion comes from the
peanut gallery
right i don't think you're vetting every
single appointee for every single agency
in a thorough manner individually how
could you you don't have the time so you
rely on the people around you and some
of the people around you are
shills globalists spooks
you know and so he he has to sort that
out i support him
and and i think he should and i think we
need him to win in 24 but i'm not gonna
hold my tongue and and and dance around
the fact that this is the moral hazard
from some of his decisions and and now
that's why he's coming out and saying i
never thought this could happen
yeah i know you didn't think it could
happen i did when george floyd pop plop
popped off in minnesota i said the state
has become tyrannical and donald trump
was the president at that time
see when donald trump ran on sovereignty
i really understood the deeper meaning
of sovereignty
he understood it in at in at his level
in his scope
now the the true sense of sovereignty is
biting him because our security state
should never be able to be weaponized
politically against the former president
that's tyranny
but here we are who's going to stop it
who's going to stand up and say
gut these institutions
irregardless of if it puts us in danger
from the iranians
i don't sleep well at night with the
belief that if the cia director isn't
there then the iranians are going to
bomb us in our in the middle of the
night
no because i'm a true american this
nation is a nation of shopkeepers
independent business owners and a second
amendment you secure your own freedom
you know wait for some shadow group
name the cia of faceless people that do
more killing of faceless individuals
around the world than they do protecting
to secure your freedom
but donald trump is a victim of that as
well new york city businessman
successful built his wealth is the
protection of the shadow is there
and whatever it is that they're doing
and their expert
expertise is protecting me it's it's
it's
okay until you wake up one day and
you're in there there's line of sight
your response yeah well no i'm i'm
hearing out uh royce over here but if
you're saying gut all these institutions
fbi caa doj everything
america needs leadership so what happens
if you gut leaders yeah no no we do we
have a crisis leadership we need new
leaders in those positions it's just
about what's the criteria
um and and our our security state and
our intelligence communities have become
uh a sidearm or a sidecar of you know
the move towards world governance and
and there's no doubt actually let's say
it this way the whole global a lot of
people say the globalism thing is a
china enterprise i see it differently
the we are the center of the globalist
agenda us
our security state
we've our security state and these
agencies have actually betrayed the
american people by partnering with the
european monarchy and putting china up
as the
the figurehead or or the you know the
the
the public face
symbol of globalism but it's really us
we're doing it with the chinese
you don't sell off you don't you don't
give away your economy to a foreign
country by accident
this is what i meant when i said
kissinger was really a democrat
what they did in china in the 70s by
opening up china as the great new
horizon and taking us off the gold
standard in the same uh
term isn't by accident who would believe
that's by accident you would have to
believe these people are idiots
and i don't i don't think kissinger's an
idiot and i don't think nixon was let's
play this out what happens here what
happens next let's play the game of what
you think will happen next what do you
think will happen next here does this
help trump does this hurt trump
uh does this get trump and which by the
way the one thing that would be not the
best thing does this actually make
desantis consider being a running mate
with trump does this bring those two
together because tyler what do you think
if those two united okay
imagine if trump and desantis are like
look man
if there's one time ever where you and i
let's just do this together
i'll go one term you take two terms
and let's go run together do you think
this unifies trump and desantis at all
i think it has to but i actually there
was a really interesting um
pairing that i saw suggested the other
day was uh donald trump and marjorie
taylor green
was i i thought was now i'm not a big
fan of mtg but but
you said something the other day that
desantis and trump are both type a
personalities
i don't know first of all i don't think
ron desantis would make the mistake of
running against trump at a primary i
think he knows exactly what would happen
i think he looks at ted cruz your your
wife looks like a dog and like he he
knows that i don't think there's any way
ron desantis yeah i'm not asking i'm not
asking marjorie i'm i'm asking
does this because here's the big concern
is those two going up against each other
right the way the left is gonna do it is
divide and conquer you gotta pin those
two against each other right you have to
do that bingo it has to be strategic
does this unify those two to say we're
both alphas but let's do this together
for four years i think it unifies them
but i don't think it puts them together
i i think i really think actually that
desantis stays in as governor of florida
he stays in florida and trump picks
another solid running mate i as as nice
as it would be and i think as powerful
as it would be i don't see that
happening
i wonder because what what purpose does
it serve what purpose does it serve to
remove ron desantis as the strongest
governor in the nation of the strongest
state in the nation right now to put him
as the vice president and then who would
backfill him who would backfill ron
desantis and who how can we guarantee
that who backfills around to santa's
keeps florida as it is florida is a
beacon right now don't think selfishly
think if you lived in tennessee forget
about forget about florida think you're
living in idaho you're not living in
florida think america more than you
think about the state we're living in
today does this bring those two together
it should
i think it should i think it won't
because in my concept desantis is
another one who is
playing the game of political strategy
in his career his individual career has
a you know he's taken a lot of risks put
his neck on the line on principle and i
respect that i respect
many of the things ron desantis has done
in a time of crisis he held the breach
and that's that's something to be that's
commendable
but
um
to what degree must be measured against
the circumstance we're in
and if he really believes that we're
under attack the way he says he does if
he really if all of these people donald
trump too if all of these people really
believe that america's existence with
our foundational values and ideas
is is facing the existential threat that
it does
all of them have to put their ego aside
and their ambitions that's something a
good christian faith would give them
it's not about me
it's not about me running at 24. it's
about what's best right now for we the
people
and for we the people a desantis trump
ticket would say
that all of the tangential political
ancillary
strategy and
trajectories and me and 24 28 none of
that matters
we're going to stand side by side based
on sacred honor
but they're going to have trouble coming
to that because neither one of them
think that way and and their in their
behavior up until this point has proved
that they think along the lines of
political strategy that's part of the
reason why trump endorsed a bunch of
candidates who don't even really who
aren't really america first but he did
it
and they end up winning i know yeah and
the maga people are raising but they're
like i mean i'm seeing it on the
grassroots level in the you know trump
is a strategist trump is not uh yeah
he's he's not at your level of uh uh his
his method of getting things done is
very different than the way you get it
done and and to my point though his
people betrayed him the first time and
he hasn't learned yet and i pray at
night
that going into this next election cycle
he will have a change of heart in mind
because his people betrayed him when you
think strategy too much sometimes
you're too smart for your own good yeah
but people so so then what jesus was uh
not the his people betrayed him yes so
that that is part of the game the part
of the game is betrayal betrayal is part
of the level you're competing at you
you're not going to be able to uh
stop a trail no man it happens that the
higher you move up the more it's going
to hurt but it's going to happen no
doubt so he's he's playing at a
different level and it's very normal for
that i i understand the way i'm
explaining it doesn't make sense like
what do you mean it's supposed to be
normal it's very normal at that level
and i'm look my criticism is just to
because
most of the criticism against me is
well you started off you know leading
these peaceful protests for george floyd
which were really more about
corporatocracy not about racism and
politics
but um it was framed that way and now
they go well now you're just a show for
donald trump or the far right i'm like
no i mean there's criticism to go around
yeah um and donald trump has a fair
share that he should reasonably get um
but you're right at that level just like
i said about him picking the the proper
even the attorney general bill barr was
probably a bad pick
um but but he trusted him uh and he and
he came up short um and and we're all
going to do that who around donald trump
has
not
uh
disabanded him who around trump is
i think
i think steve bannon did a i mean bannon
as far as trump called him sloppy steve
basically they wrote him up that's true
trump talking to steve that's not steve
talking against trump and actually steve
did very this is why i actually followed
this is why i was in
besides that steve is nail on the gun
when it comes to the issues trade china
uh most things me and him disagree on a
few things too but most things um
when donald trump lashed out at him
and he said not that's my guy
that's my guy i'm an irish boy from west
virginia we talk to each other i i've
heard worse with my brothers around the
kitchen tape that's my guy i'm sticking
by him
that's sacred honor
that's yeah but doesn't sacred honor
work both ways
sometimes it doesn't your sacred honor
is about you it's not depending on how i
act in the world
to to most degree shouldn't be based on
what he does
now if he threatens me with a gun and i
have to react physically to what he's
doing in real time that's one thing but
on principle and idea who i am shouldn't
be contingent
on who he is or what he says i have to
hold my own value so i think steve did a
great job and he stuck with i mean even
to this day other than other people
named trump and maybe kellyanne conway
who was there six years ago
that's still going to be there in 2024.
very few
and why is that
to be honest
i think many of those people
were really in it for themselves anyway
they were bandwagon writers um they
weren't they weren't patriots anyway
i'm not saying that that's why they left
him but i don't really believe like
conway's husband he's another democrat
george conway yeah he's a democrat i
mean these people aren't real
conservatives anyway so a lot of the
things that trump was trying to
push us towards are a little more
radical even than he lets on in the
public sphere because he was trying to
appease these group this group of people
that was around him can i say something
adam okay so
very good question you ask
okay very good question you ask
uh
where it gets
the audience let's just say the audience
says
why didn't they stick around
okay
so his argument is what they were not
really fully true believers they were in
and more for themselves okay all right
let's just say i give that argument 5 10
i don't give that argument 80
credibility by the way
let's say the other side is because
trump is just so hard to work with he
fires everybody i mean he had a show the
whole show was all about what you're
fired and he's all about himself
so if you're not with him 100 he fires
you how much credibility you give to
that say you give 20 30 credibility to
that whatever it is
fine
let's go there and let's say
this guy
is not the right guy to be a president
he can't keep people around his
retention sucks and his he's not picking
the right people so as much as you say
the fbi this you pick these guys right
so the person who picks him also gets
judged for
your ability to
not choose the right person you got to
be able to hire the right people right
okay you can't find your team if you're
driving but let me tell you where i go
here let me tell you where i go here
if if he's that terrible of a candidate
then guess what
leave it alone you're going to win
democrats so if he is who you say he is
the way you pose that question
then why are the democrats so afraid of
this guy that's a great so so then to me
it comes back to
if that's the can like you know how
okay so say trump would have ran against
michelle not hillary who wins
so in 2016 it's not hillary it's
michelle who wins
i think michelle huh i think michelle i
think michelle i don't know about that
by the way let me ask you a different
question say was obama's second term
who wins obama by a landslide state's
obama's first term who wins obama okay
saints clinton against trump who wins
clinton okay
do you do you see where i'm going with
this here's where i'm going with this
the point i'm trying to make is
the right was like hell yeah hillary is
running
hell
to the yeah hillary is running why
because cause she's beatable because
she's beatable she's unlikable she's
she's the worst kid
she is
there is like there's nothing about her
that's like man i want like
you know the part about obama you're
like dude you know what republicans
showed up to the first
inauguration when he gave the speech
because it was like dude the first
african you know how many republicans
yeah they should show up but no no it's
not sure it's not sure there's no such
thing as should i'm saying republican
voters showed up not the leaders oh god
people showed up to say dude freaking
i'm witnessing history there was
something you liked about obama nothing
likeable about hillary okay so the
republicans like [ __ ] we have hillary
runs go run run run why aren't democrats
feeling that way if you say he's such a
bad candidate
you should kind of like it's art of war
you know sometimes you got to get out of
the way the enemy when he's fallen
why don't you do that yeah right why
don't you do that if he's such a bad
candidate get out of his way you're
right
step back on insurrection it's not about
him
it's the ideas that they're afraid of
well to me to me they know that it's
deeper than him i i think i think to me
here's what i think to me is um
to me
is this guy is an operator
and operators are intimidating
you know why operators are intimidating
because operators don't just say things
to say them biden will say things to get
elected every 90 of people that are
running for office they'll say whatever
they can to get elected because the
history is about what it's about who got
elected right every once in a while you
find a person that you know how they say
i'm gonna kick your ass they're actually
gonna kick your ass
okay
those types of people
are very scary so to the only thing that
he
made a point that makes you think is the
following
so
let's just say
you know how how different are trump and
desantis
if they're pushing this hard
for trump
to be eliminated because they want to
indict him so he can't run what they're
really saying is we would much rather
face off the scientists than face off
trump right who do you think the
democrats would rather face
oh i totally disagree but that's your
emotional opinion but but
but but let me just be an opinion but
fine it's your opinion but let me say
this part to you
if you are saying he lost all these
people if you are saying
why did he fire all these people if you
are saying all these are bad judgment
isn't that a terrible candidate
yeah so why are you getting in his way
well look they're not just going to sit
back and just let trump do his thing
they're going to come after him but
trump can't do anything right now
how so
he what can he do right now he's not a
president he's a former president
and who who in the white house like
obama like you think you think you know
how obama control the irs obama
controlled fbi obama controls cia who
does he control nobody
who does he have control over nobody who
tell me who he has control over the
military the maga community you still
have but he still owns that but that
doesn't mean anything because policies
cannot be changed on that
all i'm saying is
he has his tentacles on people in
congress like he's not the he might not
be the king anymore i don't think so the
king maker but what do you mean all his
all his candidates won their election i
get and meanwhile you have mike pence
kind of going against him and you know
the republican establishment there's
like these proxy wars going on i want to
there's all that internal driving on the
republican party no doubt i'm taking the
angle of
your argument your argument is he's a
terrible candidate for the right okay
i'm not i'm not saying that i'm just
saying there's a ceiling with him okay
what's the ceiling 45 all right so who's
more intimidating to the left trump or
desantis
to the left to the left
i think desantis number one desantis
doesn't have the
the star quality of trump not even close
so i think we're kind of like conflating
who is it trump or desantis it's like
dude it's not even freaking close but
however in a general election yeah
desantis is way more palatable to the
general electorate than trump shouldn't
that scare the democrats
i think so yeah shouldn't they be more
about let trump run
i mean i mean they're not going to just
sit there and let trump won we already
went over the list of things that
they're trying to but then come at him
with but then there's a contradiction in
that argument why yeah then there's a
contradiction in that argument there's a
contradiction in that argument okay uh
uh uh you know as much as people said
what they said about obama the right
that was the one person they didn't want
to you know they're like this guy could
actually do something well they're still
going to always try to bring trump down
no matter like if he's at 45 percent
they're going to want to matter 40 tell
me what president they've ever done it
at this heights nobody that's my point
is that it's not going to stop but but i
i but why though is my question because
they hate the guy why though for a
billion different reasons tell me why
though give me give me five what he says
how he acts how he conducts himself you
know
the the illegal stuff that he's done the
lying the maliciousness the
vindictiveness the horrible attitude i
mean the list goes on and on and on the
reasons why people on the left hate
trump like i could write
there's novels written about this stuff
now are they justified that's a
different question are all all of those
are more of a reason to get out of his
way and let him run because he'll lose
if you are thinking he's that
that horrible of a candidate than a
leader or a letter yeah but that still
doesn't do no wait they can't subtract
the fact that he's got a major base with
them one thing though is they they can't
do what what they're really projecting
is that they know
that our entire
election
political system has become a retail
politics game of superficial personality
traits
okay it's just this the gravity of
popularity
okay in one direction or another they're
scared of trump for one reason he's got
gravity
they they don't like their they're
uncomfortable with this gravity because
they they it's it's uh
it's uh
hard for them to
determine it's hard for them to predict
it's unpredictable for them right with
obama it was it was it was a similar
thing for the opposite reason they liked
obama's gravity but they could measure
it they knew why he had the gravity
first black male
very good speaker can't you know well
polished squeaky clean is you know the
most likable guy
right um they're afraid of donald trump
because he's not a centrist
and the most dangerous people in our
society are not the people at the
extremes as much as i dislike ilhan omar
and would have uh really loved to
unseat her
um the most dangerous people aren't at
the extremes the extremes in some way
you could argue
and some people do that the cia kind of
poses them extremes like the kkk like
who's really in the kkk anymore right i
don't know i live in minnesota in the
north there's been goat folklore about
the kkk my entire life never ran into
one white people i mean minnesota are
the nicest they could be they call me
the n word behind my back when i'm not
there but they don't do it in person so
i the the painting of the white
supremacy i don't see uh in the way they
depict it but
the centrists are the most dangerous
people the centrists want an ever
expanding middle they're the purveyors
of the status quo that's who obama was
they loved that the gravity towards the
centrist in a society where people would
much rather believe
whoever
cnn tells me is going to
represent me
is going to represent me then i can go
back jerking off and getting high we
have a jerk off society
so the most dangerous people in the
jerk-off society are people who have
gravity
and a really superficial
you know vector and trump has that right
whether you're support him or not you
have to acknowledge that quality he has
that sort of gravity where people will
vote for him without really even diving
into his politics they like the way he
acts they like them right so most people
kind of do that they don't delve into
every single policy
either like trump or your doctor the
problem with trump is
let's say on two out of ten issues he's
establishment and i would say he is like
i pointed out the administrative state i
didn't think he went deep enough i
thought the trade thing with china the
20 wasn't enough
but for the other 8
out of 10 issues you don't know what
he's going to do he's unpredictable
and most the time he's going right
against the establishment status quo
obama was the flip
obama on eight out of ten issues nine
out of ten issues is gonna go for the
establishment status quo and on the one
issue he's gonna paint a a pitcher like
he's going and doing something
transformative when really it's lukewarm
at best obamacare right which is a super
gift
right for the government on the working
class i mean obamacare was a predatory
move on the american working class in
the healthcare sector no question so the
centrists are dangerous is what i'm
trying to say and desantis
all due respect it's a little more of a
centrist well and let's i think there's
a different angle you could take with
this i think
adam is right the the republican
democrat thing is weird like every i
think it's different i think you have
your globalists and your populists there
you go okay i think you could say that
nixon was a globalist or kissinger was a
globalist like don't do the republican
democrat thing they were not there
anymore that's that's not how the
parties work
i think trump is a true populist at
heart and i think the same reason
they're so afraid of trump is the same
reason they were so afraid of bernie
it's because bernie was a populist
bernie had the will of the people at
heart okay and i think that's why people
or the establishment the globalists are
so afraid of because they're afraid of
the people they know what the people are
going to do with them they know they're
going to tear them apart
can i make a point we're here to go back
to my let me let me pay you a compliment
pat i know you don't like taking
compliments but and this is there's a
trump metaphor here and go ahead and
tell me i'm an idiot and i'm wrong and
i'm getting emotional go for it but i'm
going to pay you a compliment you tell
me how you're processing this we just
came back from your big event in las
vegas
the same people that were with you when
you started php 2009 whether it's george
palayo or gate gaitan or
um ricky and erica then the names go
down the list so whether it's apollo
who's more recent
the same people jonathan mason then the
names go on the same people that were
with you in 2009
when things were tough we're not easy
you're having anxiety attacks
they're still with you on stage in 2022
saying
this is the reason that i'm here this is
my guy
thank god we have pat and are changing
all these lives and now there's ten 000
20 000 people in an arena that are
hearing people from 15 years ago who you
started out with and they're still
saying the same thing and that to me is
the definition of a leader holy [ __ ] the
people that were with me 15 years ago
when i had two nickels in my pocket i
now have two million dollars in the bank
wow those people are still with me now
what's my point
the problem that trump has is all the
people that were singing his praises in
2015 2016
90 of them are gone every single person
in his administration every general
every his attorney general bill barr his
vice president who is a bootlecker to
the extreme mike pence is no longer on
his team so my point is what is the true
definition of leadership it's the person
that
that the people who believe in you are
still
with you rather than it being some sort
of transactional hey we're in we're out
now so that's the problem with trump is
my ultimate can i get can i get my
rebuttal on sure of course
so obviously i'm very thankful for that
but also at the same time you have to
know this
we came up together
so there's a difference between them
knowing me at 30
and you know at 28 25 26 mario's known
me since i was 26 years old 27 years old
right
um
versus
he's never been in politics
so maybe that story is valid when it
goes into real estate side
because he's been in the real estate
game 45 years i don't know
okay but but in the in the politics side
when you go in
and your
first job in office is a president
not congress senate governor president
maybe you haven't had that tenure
to have built some of those deeper
relationships where they're your guys
that you can elect
the moment you go in maybe some of the
guys you pick are not your guys there
were other people's guys and their
loyalty is to that guy okay so for
example like the guys that are with us
that we build
you know company with
you know 10 years from now they may
still be me
even though i may not be there
because the loyalty is with me
we built it together even though
somebody new may come and run the
company they're going to call me say hey
the new guy's doing this what do you
think about this they're going to call
me these guys he hired are not his guys
they're somebody else's guys karl rove
they're not his guys that's the only
argument i'm making with this where i
get it i know what you're saying but uh
dude these guys have been
you're not going to change a 62 year old
person's
loyalty
who's been in an industry politics for
32 years and you coming from real estate
who has all the money gets all the
attention gets all the girls oh now you
you're the guy exactly who i hate
you're who i hate you're who i'm
secretly envious of you you're who i'm
extremely jealous of you you're the guy
i don't like i'll act like i like you i
don't like you
i can't stand you i create laws against
you
you are who i create laws against it's a
very weird dirty space that you get into
bro and
you know uh you have to play it in a
very very cautious way because
people like this will flip because
they're getting the next opportunity
coming up and they'll drop you in a
heartbeat andrew cuomo was got two years
ago guys
two years ago we were watching cuomo
brothers thinking they're gonna be
replacing jimmy kimmel and fallon we
thought they were gonna be the late
night show and then what happens both of
them get fi would you have even guessed
24 months ago august of 2020 both
cuomo's are gonna be fired you would
have guessed that one of them is going
to be a president way before you would
have guessed that both of them were
going to be fired this is a very weird
world where betrayal is an art and some
are comfortable with it some are not
and if you enter that space
you you have to have already been
stabbed so many times on the back
because you need that to be able to make
it in that space it's a very very dark i
hear you out make a very valid point at
the end of the day though character does
matter and your character whether you
were 26 and 43 now
has not wavered
the question that people have about
donald trump is his character i i don't
think anybody questions that that's fine
to say that to say the character part
fine no problem but
bro as much as people wanna okay for
example take somebody uh george soros
love him or hate him what's the guy
worth 20 billion i don't know what the
guy's worth say whatever you want to say
about the guy talking to his financial
advisor from uk right now say whatever
you want to say about the guy
you don't like the guy
you don't like the guy go make 20
billion dollars
you have to respect the 20 bill
you you don't like uh pick another
billionaire you don't like i don't know
bazels you don't like bezos go build
what he built go do it good luck to you
go ahead
go you don't like any of this
professional sports owners go do what
they did this is hard
i can be tall and jump i go into sports
i cannot automatically win in business
it's very very hard right okay to to get
to the levels he made it and have the
parties he put and everybody wanted to
party with this guy he was on all the
rap songs tupac snoop everybody the day
he announces he runs now you hate the
guy why because
that makes me a little bit uncomfortable
because that makes a little
uncomfortable
yeah so so look you know you have we
have to also be able to look past that
to say wait until 2014 he was a guy we
rapped about made shows about and
watched eyeballs we read books art of
the deal that was a book and wait all
that stuff we celebrated oh
got it
you just totally get it i get it okay
now you're gonna lose control of all the
political you know gold cards and
platinum cards you've had to get into
all the parties you don't like that guy
now all right now maybe you're the envy
one that was weak and you don't like
guys like this because you're jealous of
me okay god i see your weakness as well
no problem so there has to be that
balance between the two is all i'm
saying anyways our time's up we're at 10
59 royce uh it's been a blast having you
on you make some uh
extremely deep points there were moments
you were talking where i was just you
know with you the entire time where you
were going with it you made me think
about a lot of the topics audience i
hope you enjoyed it as much as i enjoyed
it if you did give it something thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel and he
has a podcast and a new youtube channel
i believe that you just launched let's
make sure put that in the description in
the chat box folks go subscribe follow
his content
and uh once again thanks for tuning in i
believe we are doing podcast this
thursday yeah dr uh ben carson dr ben
carson's going to be here thursday join
us looking forward to doing that royce
once again thank you brother brother
thanks for coming out this was great
take care everybody bye-bye
you